good morning good morning my lady and
the gentleman in the witness books is
Professor David Hayman CBE may he be
sawn please
I swear by almighty God but the evidence
I shall give if the evidence I shall
give shall be the truth shall be the
truth the whole truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
thank you Professor
um I'd like to begin by thanking you
um for all of the assistance that you've
given so far to this inquiry and during
the course of my questioning this
morning please keep your voice up and
speak into the microphones and so that
these stenographers can hear you clearly
and they're preparing a transcript of
your evidence if I say something that
you don't understand or you can't hear
please ask me to repeat it and I'll do
the same for you and there will be
breaks during the course of your
evidence but if at any time you require
a break please just say so thank you
Professor you have provided a report
during the course of preparation for
this inquiry could we please and put it
up on the screen thank you very much
it's uh for the record
inq30195846 this is the first page of
your report we can see Professor Heyman
that it's signed by you on the 19th of
May of this year and you have
um
signed the author's statement confirming
that it's your own work and that it's
true to the best of your knowledge and
belief and is that still the case that's
still the case yes thank you very much
um we can take that down
dealing next with your qualifications
and extensive career history and I'm
only going to concentrate for the time
being on the highlights as they are
relevant to this inquiry you are a
trained medical doctor and obtaining
your ba and MD in the United States and
you are you have a diploma in medical
epidemiology from the London School of
hygiene and tropical medicine
uh in 1976 he worked for the U.S Centers
for Disease Control investigating the
first Ebola outbreak in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo in 1976
you then worked in your first stint for
the World Health Organization between
1989 and 2009 and during that 20-year
period you headed the World Health
Organization Global Response to SARS
cov1 the severe acute respiratory
syndrome
then in 2009 you worked for the United
Kingdom Health Protection Agency as a
non-executive chair and working closely
with the chief executive during the
response to the H1N1 influenza pandemic
that we know as swine flu
you then transferred to Public Health
England in 2013 again as a non-executive
chair and during your stint there you
accompanied the phe team in 2014 to the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia to discuss and
review the data on the Middle Eastern
respiratory syndrome Cove outbreak we
know that as MERS and to offer technical
support during the course of that
investigation
um you have more recently been weak been
working again with the World Health
Organization and from 2017 you have been
the chair of the Strategic and Technical
advisory committee on infectious hazards
and you are currently professor of
infectious disease epidemiology at the
London School of hygiene and tropical
medicine that brings us up to date thank
you
um over the course of your career you've
published over 275 peer-reviewed
articles and book chapters on
communicable diseases
and and you are the editor of the
control of communicable diseases manual
and in preparing your report for us
Professor you have also provided at the
end of the report a bibliography and
list of references we don't need to go
to that now but you've also been good
enough to consider additional material
which the inquiry has obtained during
its preparation for these hearings and a
list of which has been provided to core
participants and some of which I will
take you through during your evidence
this morning
right
um in terms of the scope of your report
and that is set out in a series of
instructions which appears at Annex 2
again we don't need to go to it now but
in summary you have been asked to assist
in the following areas uh the virology
of coronavirus viruses and an
explanation of the difference between
SARS type viruses and other viruses
including influenza and the epidemiology
of covid-19 that's SARS Cove II virus
including zoonotic origin and its first
detection and an explanation of the
method by which covid-19 is transmitted
and how our understanding of that has
changed over the course of time you've
also been able to identify and provide
descriptions of some of the UK bodies
concerned with threats and some
International organizations dealing with
the global assessment of Public Health
emergencies all right well
having dealt with all of that let's
start with the basics please Professor
Heyman what are coronaviruses
well coronaviruses are viruses and
viruses unlike bacteria cannot be seen
under a routine examination with a light
microscope they need an electron
microscope they're very tiny particles
that can only be visualized that way
a coronavirus is like a sphere
surrounded by fatty material
and inside that sphere is the genetic
material of the virus the RNA
ribonucleic acid yes and on the surface
of that fatty material that ball there
are spikes which are protein and those
are the spike protein of the coronavirus
and those spikes are what Hooks on to a
receptor on a human cell
to reproduce a virus has to use that
receptor
shall I continue yes please to reproduce
a virus must enter the cell through the
receptor yes and then it takes over the
mechanism of the cell and reproduces
itself using the cell's reproductive
mechanisms all right and the spikes that
you have described do they have the
appearance of a crown and is that the
reason why it's called coronavirus
that's exactly right yes right thank you
how many types of coronavirus are there
in animals well it's not known exactly
but there are probably over 200
coronaviruses that are around the world
it's a very common virus in animal in
the animal kingdom we heard yesterday
um from um
Dr Charlotte hammer and Professor Jimmy
Whitworth that so far as animals are
concerned coronaviruses appear to be
common in bats and cats and camels is
that right that's right they're in many
many animals including even whales for
example also have coronaviruses so
they're a very common virus in the
animal kingdom are they common in
domesticated animals they they have been
shown to be able to infect domesticated
animals it's not believed that they're
common in domesticated animals except
for animals which are raised in Animal
Farms where there isn't a proper
sanitation all right well we'll come to
deal with those farms and wet markets in
a moment for how long have coronaviruses
been present in animals well it's really
not known they were they were first
identified in humans for example back in
the 1960s yes and it's known before then
that they were in animals and that
sometimes they caused outbreaks of
infection in animals but it's only
recently since the coronaviruses of the
21st century SARS for example SARS
coronavirus one yes it has really been
intensively studied in animals all right
and how easily do they transmit between
animals and between species of animals
they transmit fairly easily between
animals in in the same family we know
that from studies that have been done
with camels for example studies that
have been done that showed that minks
were able to transfer coronaviruses to
each other and it's known that they can
transmit fairly easily in the animal
kingdom
the
the animals
occasion of the ability or likelihood
that a coronavirus can jump the species
barrier between animals and humans well
jumping the species barrier is a very
complex issue really there have to be a
series of risk factors that line up in
such a way that this jumps the species
barrier and so coronavirus is due from
time to time Jump the species barrier
and when they do other viruses as well
it's not known what they will do in
humans sometimes a virus enters humans
and goes no further rabies is a good
example from a dog to a human other
times a virus can enter humans like the
Ebola virus or some other virus cause a
small outbreak disappear and then
re-emerge and finally some like HIV in
the last century emerge from animals
into humans and then they become endemic
irregular virus within humans right in
fact all infections in humans are
thought to have come at one time or
another from an animal including
tuberculosis including many common
diseases
that need to align in order to cause a
spillover or a zenosis into humans well
those risk factors depend on many
different situations really the risk
factor may be that the animal is
infected that it's being intensively
raised in Animal Farms right and then
people who are working on those Farms
could become infected or if the animals
are sent to a live market then people
who purchase those animals could be
infected it's not known what all the
risk factors are but what is known is
that the animal in human kingdoms have
to be maintained separate as well as
possible thank you
one of the documents that that you've
been good enough to look at is a is a
witness statement that's been provided
to the inquiry by Professor Mark
woolhouse in his book The Year the world
went mad he says that new human viruses
usually come from animals and most of
them don't spread well between humans do
you agree with that yes I do right and
he also says that coronaviruses are
generally more transmissible amongst
humans compared with other zoonotic
viruses and that is why they were high
on the list of viruses to worry about do
you agree with that they do transmit
fairly easily in some instances but some
coronaviruses don't transmit easily from
Human to human it depends on where they
reproduce in the human
if they reproduce low in the lungs then
it takes a deep cough or a medical
procedure that causes droplets to
transmit if they reproduce in the upper
nasal passages then it's very easy to
transmit so they're not all the same
right so that there's a variance
um
could you explain to us please the
process by which a virus becomes endemic
in humans a virus becomes endemic when
it spreads throughout human populations
and is able to sustain its transmission
from Human to human yes
okay and what factors might contribute
to a virus becoming endemic
it's a characteristic of the virus for
one thing that virus is its
transmissibility its ability to transmit
and it's also the population which is
infected if it's receptive to the virus
and it doesn't have protection against
it it can transmit if there's a
population that has solid immunity
against the virus then it can't transmit
further right
um You were good enough in the course of
your report to describe to us the the
four coronaviruses which are endemic in
humans and for the record they are 229 e
n l 63 OC 43 and
hkui and
what do those letters and numbers mean
is that is there any is there any format
behind the nomenclature there's clearly
a format be behind them and it depends
on when they were named what that format
was there's an international taxonomy
Group which does name viruses and they
have altered the way they do that
periodically so I can't explain exactly
what each one means but they do have a
name and that name is with them today
all right thank you
um
how severe or or how mild are the upper
respiratory infections caused by those
coronaviruses those coronaviruses
generally cause a common cold right
they're common cold viruses so fairly
mild they're fairly mild except in some
people who might have comorbidities or
the elderly who are debilitated because
their immune system is not responding
the way it should right and what about
young children are they more at risk
young children are not considered to be
a great risk from Human coronaviruses
but they do get common colds and those
common colds are coronavirus sometimes
right and What treatments or vaccines
are available for those for
coronaviruses well there are no vaccines
available in fact they're considered to
be very mild viruses and so the usual
remedies that are used to treat a common
cold are used to treat them what are the
roots of transmission for them the roots
of transmission are from the low those
are the nasal passages through a sneeze
or a cough on another person droplets
and particles aerosolized particles and
how long would it take
for there to be long-term immunity from
from those for coronaviruses well long
term I'd rather talk about population
immunity population immunity yes is when
the majority of the population has had
infection has developed antibody or
response to that is that also sometimes
known as herd immunity they're different
herd immunity is an immunity which
protects against re-infection yes or
it's a vaccine that protects against
infection
and with the SARS coronavirus too we
don't have either of those factors
available
so in fact herd immunity at present
cannot be established from the SARS
coronavirus too right and what's the
difference between that and population
immunity population immunity is General
under understanding of all the
population immune systems of the virus
right with a response with antibody
usually and therefore that population
immunity in the case of the SARS
coronavirus II prevents serious illness
and death in most people right
I'd like to ask you some questions now
about the
procedure that you set out in paragraphs
18 and 19 of your report we don't need
to look at them but it's the molecular
clock analysis that was undertaken of
coronavirus OC 43 first of all Professor
can you explain to us what the molecular
clock analysis is
yes molecular clock analysis is an
attempt to understand the rate of
mutation of a virus so from the animal
into the no the rate of a mutation in a
human or within a human right now what
was done in 2004 and which was very
important to note and is the fact that a
group of molecular biologists calculated
a rate of mutation of human coronavirus
the SARS coronavirus no I'm sorry of
human coronavirus OC 43. and they
calculated that rate of mutation by
taking all the known specimens that they
could find of oc43 virus from 1950s
onward they genetically sequenced them
and each one had a slight difference in
its genetic structure and that's a
mutation yes and so they calculated a
rate of mutation of that virus going
forward to 2003. yes they did the same
thing with the virus that comes from
cattle because cattle were the source or
the expected source of OC 43 originally
in humans yes and so they calculated the
rate of mutation in cattle as well and
then they took those rates of mutation
and worked them backwards from the
present time yes to where both of those
viruses would have looked the same where
they wouldn't have mutated and that
occurred between 1850 and 1890.
in 1888 1889 there was a pandemic called
the Russian influenza
and these molecular biologists
hypothesized that this was the emergence
of OC 43 because the pandemic that
occurred was not exactly what occurs
with influenza there were many deaths a
million deaths in a very small world
that it caused neurological symptoms in
most persons right and so they
hypothesized that this was the emergence
of OC 43 which then became a virus which
causes the common cold today because of
population immunity which is protecting
against serious illness and death so by
using the molecular clock analysis they
were confident to within a certain time
period of when the disease jumped into
the human population that's correct they
used three different methods and they
came out with the same with each of
these Metals right and has that
procedure been undertaken in relation to
what we now know is covered 19. there
was an attempt by some molecular
biologists in the U.S to calculate uh
molecular to do a molecular clock
analysis of SARS coronavirus II yeah and
in doing their analysis they went
backwards from the time when it was
first identified to where it might have
been very close to the virus that's
similar in bats and they came to about a
period of October 2019.
but this is just one of many hypotheses
as you know yes
well thank you
um I'm now going to ask you a series of
questions about 20th century
coronaviruses so we'll start with SARS
move on to MERS and then finish with at
covid-19
at paragraph 21 in your report you tell
us that SARS is thought to have emerged
from an animal likely to be a Civic cat
in a live animal Market in the Guangdong
Province of China Sometime Late in 2002.
is that right that's correct yes and it
too have resulted from a one-time
mutation of the virus reproduced either
in the animal host before transmission
to humans or in humans after the
emergence had occurred that's correct
yes
is it right that the presence of
antibodies in the blood of workers in
live animal markets suggests that they
had previously been infected with other
coronaviruses which had not gone on to
transmit human to human that's correct
that comes from a study which was done
by Chinese after the SARS outbreak in
2003 right
and from the live animal Market in
Guangdong
um SARS went on to spread amongst health
workers in provincial Health Facilities
through a combination of close physical
contact with infected patients and
medical procedures that cause pulmonary
aerosols is that right yes that's
correct the Chinese were never
forthcoming at the beginning with their
information but this is the Assumption
right what sort of medical procedures
produce pulmonary aerosol
but when there's a severe respiratory
infection such as SARS coronavirus there
is a lot of mucus that builds up in the
lungs yes and to get that mucus out to
help the patient breathe easier there's
an infusion through the nose and a tube
of saline which is salt water
body on salt water and then it's um the
the lungs are fleshed out the the water
is pulled out and along with that is the
mucus that's been softened and absorbed
by the water and droplets are many times
caused as a result of that and I'll
that procedure the same or smaller or
lighter than aerosols generated by
normal voice projections such as
speaking loudly or singing I think it's
useful to look at an aerosol as being on
a spectrum of droplets which are heavy
in Fall to lighter particles which are
carried by the air to very light
particles so it's a whole range of
things and these particles contain virus
right and what stops the the virus from
spreading
the virus is able to to transmit and
cause infection as long as the
surrounding material which is many times
mucous is moist right if it dries out
the virus can no longer infect
so is that why ventilation
um assists in in preventing transmission
because the airflow will will assist in
drying out the particles that's correct
all right
at paragraph 21 in your report you say
that there was substandard infection
prevention and control in the Guangdong
Health Facilities how so
well all we know is the the graph that
the Chinese finally produced for this
outbreak shows that health workers
became infected very early in the
outbreak and those health workers then
continue to become infected and it's
assumed that they infected their family
members and other patients and one of
those health workers actually came out
of Guangdong Province into Hong Kong in
February of 20 of
2003-2003 and from him the virus was
spread to people staying in the same
hotel and it spread around the world so
health workers are very important always
in emerging infections because they
don't recognize that they're a new
disease oftentimes yes do you know for
instance Professor whether or not those
health workers were routinely wearing
PPE such as face masks or Shields I
think it can be assumed that early on
they weren't because with the Chinese
indicated when they finally opened up to
providing information is they thought
that this was influenza right and they
therefore were not worried that it was a
new infection okay thank you
um so it saws Covey one was first
identified as a novel coronavirus by
genetic sequence sequencing in March of
um which was
about three months after its emergence
and do you have any comment to make on
the length of time that it took to to
identify as a novel coronavirus well the
virus was first isolated from a patient
in February yes in late February and so
it was very rapid impact that it was
understood that it was a Coronavirus
which countries were affected by SARS
well they were uh initially there were
about seven countries were infected
because these were people who were
staying on the same Hotel yes and I
think in my testimony I've said it goes
to it went to 21 or 22 different
countries and that included countries
around the world The Good the good if
there was good in this outbreak was that
it didn't appear to make its way into
Africa where surveillance might not have
detected it and it might have spread
even further than it did yeah and you've
described the
um the virus reproducing um deep in the
lungs which would require uh deep
coughing or a pulmonary pulmonary
procedures to create the droplets or
aerosols that you've described
um
was that a major factor in the control
of SARS I believe it was yes there were
several factors that were important
number one SARS coronavirus one is not
transmissible or highly transmissible
until two or three days after the onset
of signs and symptoms right unlike SARS
coronavirus too okay is that is that the
in period That's the period from no the
incubation period is the period from
infection to Onset to onset of symptoms
yeah so that was one of the factors it
wasn't transmissible early right after
it was only transmissible after signs
and symptoms developed right the second
thing it produced reproduced deep in the
lungs and therefore was very difficult
to transmit there had to be really deep
coughing and close contact with others
and finally there was a willingness of
the world at that time to work together
and so countries agreed not to travel to
places where there were uncontrolled
outbreaks of SARS coronavirus one which
included Singapore Hong Kong and Canada
and so the outbreak was one that was
contained rapidly and I think you could
say that that virus now has gone from
Human populations it's been eradicated
thank you
during the evidence of Professor
Whitworth and Dr Hammer yesterday we
heard about something called the case
fatality rate yes um is that the number
of confirmed deaths caused by a virus in
relation to the number of confirmed
infections no confirmed cases confirmed
cases sorry yes and the
rate is less certain because there are
those who may be infected
asymptomatically that's true so that
does that's not based upon confirmed
cases that's correct yes now it the case
fatality rate of SARS was utilizing your
report close to 10 percent that's
correct
um in comparison to case fatality rates
for MERS which we're going to move on to
in a moment which was about 35 percent
and the case fatality rate for covid-19
which is around about the one percent
mark
um can you explain to us
um what danger lies in the phenomenon of
Under reporting and how that has to be
factored in in determining either the
case fatality rate or the infection
fatality rate yes well um in infection
fatality rate it's very difficult to
know all the infections unless you test
the entire population yes and so the
infection rate case fatality rate would
be the number of deaths from that
infection based on the whole population
that has infection
case fatality rates are based on a Case
definition
and a case definition describes what a
disease is thought to look like by the
persons who develop that case definition
usually the Public Health Community
then okay
sorry
then all cases that are fit that case
definition must be tested yes and must
be shown to have that infectious agent
and is that a Laboratory test that's a
laboratory test yes and then the case
the death rate is those people who were
shown to be infected who died so they're
included in the case number that they're
a separate number they're the fatality
number as well all right now you've
described there a case description
um is that the symptoms that have to be
present in order for a case to to
Warrant at the description that's right
in an outbreak investigation or whenever
there's a new disease a case definition
is rapidly developed based on what's
known at that time but that would change
over time absolutely it can change over
time and it generally does change over
time
um
could we display
inq30s198-953
I think you've had an opportunity of of
looking at this before Professor Heyman
this is a table which has been taken
from a video lecture that Professor
Chris Whitty gave to Gresham College
London on how to control a pandemic in
2018. now if we just
familiarize ourselves with what we have
the vertical axis shows the level of
transmission and the horizontal axis
shows the level of mortality
and if we start from the least serious
moving up to the most serious bottom
left-hand Corner low transmission and
low mortality the boxing green
Professor Whittier said not worth
worrying about so that that is the least
serious table but part of the table
isn't it if if a if if a pandemic is
thought to have low transmission and low
mortality that's the least serious of
the four that we see here
the next
next to in seriousness is the Box above
so the the yellow box above which is
high transmission but low mortality rate
do you agree with that yes and
an example that's been given here is the
H1N1 2009 swine flu which we see
according to this table has a mortality
rate of 0.3 but between 10 and 200
million cases so very high transmission
yes
next in line if we go to the bottom
right hand corner we can see the
pandemic with low transmission but High
mortality in that box the example given
is the h7n9 avian flu from 2013 to 2018
with 30 mortality but around 2 000
confirmed cases so very low transmission
there yes I wouldn't call this a
pandemic though this is not a pandemic
this is outbreaks of this disease which
occur occasionally the disease has not
is not pandemic as such in humans but it
is it appears to be in in Birds right
thank you and then finally top right
hand corner we can see in the pink box
the pandemic with high transmission and
high mortality rate at the example given
there is the H1N1 to 1918 Spanish Flu
with around three percent mortality do
you have any comment to make about that
box yeah that it's always been
interesting to me to see how virologists
and others like to compare the current
situation to 1918 which was a pandemic
of influenza but which also was an ERA
when there were no antibiotics
and though antibiotics will not clear
influenza they will clear superficial
bacterial infections that occur in the
lungs when they've been robbed of their
lining by influenza virus
and so the mortality was high much of
that mortality was likely due to
superficial bacterial infections and so
we don't really know the mortality from
H1N1 Spanish Flu directly from the virus
we only know that on top of that there
were bacterial okay so it could have
been a combination of the virus and then
the the bacteria that's generally the
thinking yes all right thank you
just before we leave this table are you
able to assess where covid-19 might
appear in relation to the level of
transmission and mortality
I I would place the coronavirus SARS
coronavirus II I'm on this table excuse
me let's see I need to think a bit I
will I would place this virus I believe
on the high mortality end and so I would
place it high transmission High
mortality right so top right hand corner
in the pink box thank you
we can take that down please
what are the symptoms and clinical
outcomes of SARS or what what were the
symptoms and clinical outcomes SARS was
a very severe respiratory infection
which caused respiratory failure people
could no longer breed yeah the outcome
of that was that there was a high case
fatality rate of 10 percent
and in addition many people who
recovered had what's called pulmonary
fibrosis right which means that their
lungs were replaced the the breathing
the area where oxygen Exchange in the
lungs occurs was replaced with fibers
which didn't permit exchange of oxygen
and so some of those people still today
have severe consequences from having had
this infection are you able to to say
how the the ongoing outcomes of SARS
compare to those of covid-19 it's too
early yet to say the long-term effects
of this but certainly like other viruses
including for example the virus that
causes mononucleosis there is a period
afterwards where people are still
fatigued still sick and in covid-19 it
appears that there are many many more
symptoms that are occurring in these
people remember this is an animal virus
that it adapted itself to animals and
now it's in humans right okay
between
asymptomatic transmission and
asymptomatic infection
asymptomatic infection is people who
become infected with an organism and
never show signs and symptoms that's
asymptomatic infection so so never any
any development of anything never
developed signs and symptoms from that
virus
asymptomatic transmission
is when a virus or a bacterium in this
case a virus when a virus is being shed
by the person before onset of signs and
symptoms and that can then transmit to
others and we know that occurs for
example with measles which is a
respiratory infection it occurs two to
three days beforehand and many virus
infections are thought to transmit
before the onset of Sciences right so so
asymptomatic transmission is the
transmission before any signs or
symptoms but after which the person may
well develop something that's correct
yes thank you they will develop signs
and symptoms they will
um
what's up just just to to complete this
part of your evidence what then is
pre-symptomatic transmission is that the
same as asymptomatic transmission
I would say they're the same yes right
um at paragraph 29 in your report you
say that SARS was transmitted primarily
but not exclusively in healthcare and
Hospital settings
um and that the majority of patients
were adults between 25 and 70 years of
age and that the investigations did not
identify groups at greater risk of
serious outcomes after infection is that
right why do you think there were so few
suspected or confirmed cases of
infection in children under the age of
15. as we understand this it was
transmitted in hospital settings by
procedures such as cleaning out of the
lungs and therefore it was in patient
adult patient care areas and the nurses
who became infected or the health
workers who became infected and
transmitted it to others were
transmitting in an adult patient boards
not in children's words with SARS did
infection provide immunity against
re-infection it's not known it's not
known anyone there were too few cases to
really study that
and so what factors led to its
containment after a period of about six
months I think you said well those
factors I reviewed earlier was the fact
that it was very difficult to transmit
from Human to human it required very
close contact with droplet spread the
world worked together to limit
travel to where outbreaks were occurring
yes and it didn't get into countries
where there was poor surveillance which
might not have detected it and permitted
it to spread further that was the
reference to Africa and so it didn't
become endemic in humans it did not
become endemic all right so professor
something you said just now you said
transmission was thought to be in
hospital settings so
um it was by treating adult patients
that the hospital workers got infected
and then they were dealing with adult
Wards but why weren't the hospital
workers then going home where there were
children so children would get infected
that way they did go home and they did
transmit it in the household and some
children were infected but the majority
of people who were infected were adults
when did the the last known human
infection occur and how did it occur
the last known human infections of SARS
coronavirus II the notes oh sorry verse
one sorry the last human infections of
SARS coronavirus 1 occurred in
laboratory accidents one in Singapore
one in Taiwan and several outbreaks
caused by laboratory accidents in China
right
let's move on to MERS please
um
first identified in the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia in June of 2012.
humans became infected from close
contact with camels as we heard
yesterday
um
was the route of transmission between
the species through droplets or bodily
secretions or feces or the combination
of all three between humans yes yes in
SARS in in Merced coronavirus there is
transmission from person to person by
Body secretions or by droplets or
similar close contact it occurs in
hospital settings called nosocomial
infection when health workers don't
practice washing of their hands or
whether they're using equipment which
has not been properly sterilized between
patients
that's the major means in which
coronavirus transmits from person to
person how many k icks were there in the
United Kingdom
there have been five cases known in the
United Kingdom the three importations of
the virus so the virus was first
imported in 2012 yes and since then
there have been two other importations
in one of those importations was
transmitted to a person who had
accompanied the the patient and also to
a visitor of the patient right
there was then a second second major
outbreak in the Republic of Korea in
when an infected person returned home
from the Middle East they brought it
from the Middle East and became ill and
was seen at various Health Facilities
yes is that right and again substandard
infection control at those facilities
which led to the infection there that's
correct there were many factors that
were thought to have caused this to
spread so rapidly one of those was the
fact that the patient went to three
different health facilities and the
infection prevention and control
measures in all of those facilities was
substandard we're poor yes we're going
to come to that in a moment but in total
um your report tells us that there were
185 cases in this outbreak with 38
deaths
um so that's that's a case fatality rate
of 20 or thereabouts in the South Korea
outbreak
um
there were you tellers uh in your report
a series of factors causing
um the the infection to spread
um and you've you've begun to tell us
about that that there was weak hospital
infection control
um weak patient isolation procedures is
that right leading to infection of of
other patients and family members and
also a nursing shortage
so that led to a dependence on private
less well-trained caregivers is that
right correct yeah and extremely crowded
emergency departments without any
isolation beds
but it was rapidly contained was it not
Professor Heyman within a couple of
months
that's correct
was that that containment down to
Indian policies in the hospital setting
and an improvement in the infection
controls that's correct there was an
improvement in infection control after
retraining of hospital staff there was
also an increase in ventilation in
hospitals which dried out those virus
particles as as we've already discussed
yeah and and there was also um an
understanding by the population because
of good communication what this virus
was doing and how to prevent infection
so there was a major effort at
communication which is always important
right in outbreaks and does it follow
from what you've just said that the the
main or the primary route of
transmission of MERS was through
droplets or aerosols in the same way
that that we've um
um
were there any super spreading events in
relation to MERS and can you describe to
us what a super spreading event is
please yes there were there were um
super spreading in in which virus
immersed in Mars yes in Mars there have
been some super spreading events um this
was one in South Korea yes for example
and there have been events where there
have been several different cases in
hospitals where one person was admitted
but it's been very Patchwork the
understanding of this virus because
there hasn't been clear and transparent
sharing of information in many instances
right
and what what is a super spreading event
in in in scientific terms a super
spreading event is when a person who is
infected for some reason or another is
able to infect many many other people so
it may be due to the fact that there are
many people in a very small closed space
and the person is able to transmit
because he's at the right or she is at
the right phase of transmission and then
transmit super spreading events are
events that occur when the risk factors
line up in such a way that they can
occur right so what we have described
happening in the hospital setting in
South Korea that would be described
properly as a super spreading event even
something on that fairly contained small
scale yes right
wasmers capable of asymptomatic
transmission
it's not yet known whether asymptomatic
transmission occurs among humans but
clearly it occurs from Camels to humans
the disease is now endemic in camels
the virus is carried in the nasal
passages and transmit quite easily to
humans right
it's endemic in camels yes but not in
humans not in human right
um
all right well that brings us to covert
19.
um it's no part of this inquiry to
debate or to determine the origin of
covid-19 but
um you attempt to assist us in your
report by setting out
um what you consider to be the theories
of origin
um can you explain to us please
professor at what those consist of
there are two major theories about the
emergence of this virus in the human
populations
one is that it occurred it came from a
bat into an intermediary animal
and from that animal in humans possibly
at a live animal Market that's one
hypothesis right the other is that there
was a laboratory accident at a major
highly secure laboratory in Wuhan
and that laboratory we know was dealing
with bats that had Coronavirus and that
laboratory the hypothesis is that either
the virus was able to escape from
studies that were going on in a human
who left and was infected or through
some other means and the hypothesis then
concludes in some instances the other
hypothesis is that the virus was being
manipulated in such a way that it gained
function it gained the possibility of
transmitting easily between humans so
these are all hypotheses and what's
important from them is that there are
messages that we can use we need to make
sure that live animal markets are
conducted in the right way that the
animals that come to those markets are
raised in conditions where they can't
become infected and at the same time
there need to be better standards of
Laboratories high security Laboratories
and those standards need to be developed
by the people working with viruses and
adhere to by them right so between those
hypotheses you aren't able to to say
which one is is more likely or which one
is is more probable
I'm not able to say that because I don't
have the evidence no but but they are
both they're both hypotheses
um
in terms of the sequence of events at
the start of the pandemic and the global
spread
um are you able to explain to us
Professor Heyman how that happened in
the immediate outbreak in China and um
and how that that traveled around the
world
well there again are some hypotheses on
this and some evidence from that but
it's felt that it was possible that the
The Province where this outbreak began
was suppressing information about it for
some reason or another and that when the
central government did understand that
it was going on they reported it to who
that's one of the hypotheses that's what
many people believe it doesn't really
matter now what happened back then we
have to deal with the virus as it is
today and who when they received the
report on the 31st of December in 2019
the next day did provide information
about it and then continue to provide
information about the virus through
What's called the international Health
regulation system yes well we'll come to
that in a moment and before we look at
the the advice that the World Health
Organization gave in the immediacy of
the outbreak I I'd just like to return
to to something that that you've now
confirmed in relation to all three of
these coronaviruses so SARS Mars and
what we now know as as covid-19 you've
referred to
um what I'm going to describe as a lack
of Candor or a lack of information a
lack of willingness to share information
um on behalf of some countries
um why is that such a problem
well when a country shares information
about a disease it often has economic
repercussions yes for example if a
country says that they have cholera then
other countries may stop importing
Seafood from that country tourists may
stop going to that country and so
countries don't like to report
and so in in discussions at who it was
understood that because there's no
International policy policing mechanism
to force countries to report the way to
do it was to change the norm so the
country's understood it was expected and
respected to report and that's what the
director general of who did during the
SARS outbreak in 2003 how did he do that
she actually announced publicly uh four
months after the outbreak had begun that
China was not sharing information with
who and therefore who couldn't do a full
risk assessment of what was going on and
what happened did that have a a
repercussion or an effect that had an
immediate effect in that the vice
Premier Madame Wu Yi immediately
traveled to Geneva
apologized to the director General and
immediately began to share information
in China was able to stop the outbreak
very the breaks throughout China very
rapidly so after that it's become
understood that it's expected and
respected and most countries now
continue to report including China and
what about MERS was it was the same
procedure adopted in relation to the
concerns about a lack of information
sharing that there was hesitancy of the
government of Saudi Arabia to report it
to start and one of the doctors who had
been treating the initial patient
thought it was SARS coronavirus one
and he did a genetic sequence and put
that public publicly that sequence
publicly and fortunately it was in the
public domain because that's how the UK
knew that they had a case imported right
and then more recently then with with
covid-19 what concerns have been
expressed internationally about a lack
of information sharing from China in the
early days yes there were there was
concern about a lack of sharing of
information I don't want to take a
position on that
who did receive information did put it
out to countries yes and countries in
Asia took that information very rapidly
and acted upon it right these were
countries that had had SARS previously
and they were very attuned to SAR to
coronaviruses all right well we'll
return in a moment to deal with those
countries and what perhaps could have
been learned by their experiences and
why they were able to to react so
quickly to to covid-19 when it um when
it started to spread but but returning
for a moment please to the to the
initial outbreak
um
what
reports and recommendations were
provided internationally by the World
Health Organization about travel or
travel restrictions
well who
recommended in its first emergency
commit second emergency committee
meeting after that who took the
recommendation of the emergency
committee which said that there should
not be an interruption of travel and
trade especially for humanitarian
purposes if it was required to ship
goods or other other equipment to
countries and do you understand and
concur with that advice in general I do
yes in fact the best defense against the
spread of international infections is
good strong National surveillance and
detection mechanisms right and what do
you mean by that what I mean by that is
that countries have surveillance systems
which can detect unusual events very
early yes whether it's reported from a
community or reported from an emergency
department or from the health system in
general and that in your opinion it is a
is a better
um that the surveillance is is a better
method of of controlling an initial
outbreak or reacting to an initial
outbreak than travel restrictions yes
because infections can travel
asymptomatically in persons who don't
develop signs and symptoms until they've
crossed that international border yeah
and so it's a false security to think
that borders can stop infections
in later modules to this inquiry we will
look at the advice which was issued for
preventing the infection spreading
throughout the United Kingdom but
laying the groundwork now in terms of
mask wearing if I may and at paragraph
83 of your report you confirm that the
World Health Organization on the 29th of
January of 2020 recommended wearing a
medical mask alone during home care and
in healthcare settings in the community
and that that offered adequate
protection against transmission if
combined with hand hygiene and other
infection prevention and control
measures but that a medical mask was not
required for individuals without
respiratory symptoms in a community
setting and that there was no evidence
at that time on its usefulness to
protect non-sick persons yes it's that
was who's recommendation yeah and do you
have any comment to make about that
advice that was provided on the 29th of
January that was solid advice to prevent
Transmission in care settings and it was
very important and medical masks have
been recommended were recommended for
health workers
and but it wasn't until much later I
think in in 2022 that the World Health
Organization unreservedly recommended
mask wearing for the general public
Whenever there was a need to increase
did to decrease Community spread
um but you would say I I presume
Professor that by that time there was so
much more evidence available that's
right and who doesn't like to make
recommendations without an Evidence base
they don't like to make precautionary
recommendations which are
recommendations which would be modified
as evidence comes in
so
to be with a description that the
initial advice back in January of 2020
and displays a hesitancy of the World
Health Organization in in advising that
mask wearing was appropriate or or is it
your evidence Professor that that in
fact that was solid taking into account
the very limited amount of evidence that
was present at that time yes who has
said that the reason they didn't
recommend earlier is because they didn't
have the evidence to make that
recommendation all right and as you've
just said that that the evidence base is
extremely important it's very important
yes for the world but there can be
precautionary measures that are made
recommendations that are made which were
not made by who at that time
even taking into account that covid-19
is a is a fairly recent disease
are you aware of
case studies in China
around the asymptomatic transmission of
the virus
there was a study early on about
asymptomatic transmission in a household
that again the case definition was not
clear what was being used and it was not
really it was published and it was peer
reviewed early on but it wasn't really
clear that this was an article to be
found there were very few number of
family members involved the evidence
really came from Singapore when they
were able to look at seven different
clusters of persons who were infected
and were unable to link them to people
who had clinical signs and symptoms
right but people who they were able to
link them to in context some of them did
later on develop signs and symptoms all
right you've mentioned again there the
case definition
are you able to help us Professor with
with how the case definition of covid-19
may have altered over time based upon
the increasing evidence yes early on the
case definition in China for example was
a case definition of a very serious
illness which required hospitalization
yes so they only were finding those
serious cases because that's what they
were looking for when other cases were
likely occurring as well right
I ask you to explain for us please the
the reproductive number
just running at any problems
I think mine is my lady oh is it or
maybe just it's me
I seemed to stop rolling sorry forgive
me
it was just me
foreign
I was asking your professor about the
reproductive number can you explained to
us what it is and how it relates to
covid-19 please the reproductive number
is the number of people who become
infected from a person who's able to
transmit the virus or bacteria right so
if a reproductive number is four that
means that one person can infect four
other persons provided there's no
immunity among the persons to which that
person is exposed yes all right and in
relation to covid-19 has the
reproductive number dropped over the
course of time reproductive numbers drop
as the number of people in a population
become immune either from vaccination or
from disease and so the reproductive
number has dropped in in the UK for
example it's now thought to be less than
one yes which is what cannot sustain
transmission right
could we display please paragraphs 99 to
101 of Professor Hayman's witness
statement his report which is at inq
triple zero one nine five eight four six
thank you I'm just going to to read
through this uh with you Professor
Heyman
um dealing with the the various symptoms
of covert 19.
um it's currently estimated that up to
33 of those infected in highly
vaccinated populations do not develop
recognizable signs and symptoms of
infection after vaccination or on
reinfection except for those with
comorbidities including obesity the rest
have a broad range of mild to severe
signs and symptoms that can include a
new and continuous cough
anosmia that's loss of smell
aguzia that's loss of taste and a range
of non-specific signs and symptoms
including shortness of breath fatigue
loss of appetite myalgia that's muscle
ache sore throat headache nasal
congestion stuffy nose runny nose
diarrhea nausea and vomiting
decreased blood oxygen saturation is a
Hallmark of serious illness after
infection with SARS cov2 and
complications include respiratory
failure acute respiratory distress
syndrome that's odds sepsis and septic
shock
thromboembolism and or multi-organ
failure including acute kidney injury
and cardiac injury and if we can just
move up please to complete this at
paragraph 101 infections in the elderly
and in others from deprived areas and or
from certain non-white ethnic
backgrounds have caused more serious
illness in death
underlying health conditions such as
diabetes and chronic renal disease as
well as obesity likewise increase the
risk of severe disease and death in
adults
now that collection of symptoms and
effects were not known about it on the
immediate transmission back in December
of 2019 so does that picture build over
the course of time as
um as the the as as the transmission
increases and and we are able to see a
variance in terms of the case definition
and does that expand yeah and yes this
is called the natural history of
infection right all the signs and
symptoms that are associated at one
point or another with infection and it
does modify as more information is
obtained and focus is not on persons who
are seriously ill but on persons who
have a positive diagnosis but have less
serious illness and this often depends
on being able to identify an infection
by a Laboratory test right
why is it Professor that symptoms may be
more severe for those who have
comorbidities in particular obesity
well in obesity it's thought that there
is a physical component to that whereas
it's very difficult in an obese or an
obese person to breathe at times
especially when there's a pulmonary
infection making it very difficult to
exchange oxygen right at the same time
persons who are obese have a greater
risk of diabetes too and diabetes
decreases the immune response to
infections it's known that that occurs
with bacterial infections and it also
occurs With viral infections right thank
you very much we can take that off the
screen now
um just before we we break I'm conscious
of the time my lady and how long the
stenographer has been working there have
been some difficult words too yes
transcribe
um is that a convenient what it is yes
very well I think probably we'll take a
break
um I shall return at 20 plus 11. thank
you
foreign
thank you my lady
and we were talking about the
um facets of of covid-19 and the various
aspects of it and that are important and
that perhaps set it apart from other
viruses
and I'd like to turn to ask you please
about the incubation period what do we
know about that so far
well the incubation period is the period
as we talked earlier from the time of
infection yes time of onset of signs and
symptoms yeah and it's thought to be
anywhere between 2 and 14 days although
it will become more precise as more
analysis of information becomes
available right how does that come
for instance the incubation period of
influenza influenza has a shorter
incubation period about one to three
days or four days so it's a much shorter
incubation period and therefore a virus
can increase
much more rapidly in infecting people
than can one with a longer incubation
period right
um we've talked or touched upon on herd
immunity and you've explained to us what
that is
um
does the incubation period have any
connection to herd immunity or or how
often or sorry how quickly how rapidly
um a population can can become immune to
a disease
yes in fact the more rapid the the
shorter the incubation period the more
rapidly the virus can spread yes and
therefore cause an immune response in
the people who are infected right thank
you and moving on to deal with the
current figures for Global deaths and
cases from covid-19 as of the end of May
of this year
um globally there were
767 million cases and close to 7 million
deaths and those are the official
figures
and what is your opinion Professor about
the danger of relying upon official
figures and whether or not in reality
those figures are likely to be
considerably higher
well when reporting
um
figures it depends on many different
things country the reporting of cases by
countries confirmed cases depends on
their testing strategy right so some
countries have a much higher testing
rate than other countries some countries
didn't bother doing testing at all and
so the reporting of cases is usually
based on confirmed cases and and that
depends on the testing strategy other
countries May report suspect cases it
may not be clear in those statistics who
reported suspect cases who reported
confirmed cases and again the confirmed
cases depend on the laboratory strategy
so cases are not a good way of
evaluating or at least comparing one
country to another
deaths however are a much more solid
figure because deaths usually occur in a
hospital setting in most countries or
many times do and therefore that's a
better indication if it's a confirmed
death of the number of cases that are
occurring if you
um is there a difference between how
some countries interpret a death caused
by covet 19.
there is in fact it depends on what's on
that death certificate in many countries
and sometimes there are comorbidities
that have been become the cause of death
but they were the cause of death because
of a covet infection yet it's reported
as being a death from one of those
comorbidities
and so the economist has recently
calculated excess deaths globally as
being in the region of 22 million and
that's a that's a much higher figure
threefold
um higher than um the the confirmed
level of seven million deaths globally
yes in those excess deaths would also
include deaths of people who could not
obtain health care for routine problems
during a pandemic or the epidemic and
therefore added higher rates of
mortality causing more excess death
right so so excess deaths is is not in
itself an indication of deaths caused
for certainty by covert 19. no it's
that's correct all right
I'm
I'd like to ask you now some questions
about the level of preparedness of Asian
countries
for covid-19 those who had experience of
SARS and MERS in their recent history
what effect do you think having
a serious outbreak of those two previous
coronaviruses had on countries such as
Singapore Japan South Korea Taiwan and
Hong Kong
I believe they had a profound effect on
those countries in fact I visited some
of those countries during the period
after SARS and before the current
pandemic and some of those countries had
actually established isolation Wards
with hundreds of beds in their hospitals
ready for when there should be an
outbreak such as this so they were
developing surge capacity in those
countries at the same time as they were
training their health workers in in
procedures such as contact tracing so
they they appeared to be much better
prepared because of what they had
learned from the SARS outbreaks back in
2003 so you've mentioned two things
there surge capacity within hospitals a
training of health workers in contact
tracing why was that second element so
important that element was important
because early in the outbreak countries
such as Japan for example did not only
contact tracing looking forward to see
who was in contact with the person who
was sick but also Look Backwards to try
to find the source of infection and when
they found that they then did what they
called a Precision lockdown they locked
down where the source of infection was
that's good basic epidemiology and
outbreak control and they did this in
countries such as Singapore in South
Korea in Japan and in Taiwan and other
places as well
controlling the spread it certainly
appears it was effective yes in fact
they were able to stop outbreaks that
were major outbreaks in South Korea
there was a major outbreak around the
church event as there was in Singapore
and those outbreaks were completely
contained and stopped which permitted
those countries to let the virus enter
at a much lower rate because there were
fewer people infected to infect
community members but to be effective at
decision lockdown has to take place very
quickly after knowledge is being gained
that the virus is spreading that's
correct yes before it gets out any
further that's correct right and those
countries
um who had
the ability because of the training of
the healthcare workers to undergo
contact tracing and and then to to set
up a Precision lockdown were more
successful in continuing the early
spread of Kobe 19. it's my view that
they were and if you look at the results
of that today you'll see that their
mortality rates were much are much much
lower in mortality rates reported
mortality rates in many European most
European countries all right well well
let's take a look please at paragraphs
113 and 114 of your report
thank you
113 and 114 please
next page
thank you if we could highlight those
two paragraphs please
so just to confirm what you have told us
Professor early in the covid-19 pandemic
studies in Japan traced contacts of
persons with covid-19 forward for
isolation and monitoring and backward to
the source of infection they then shut
down those areas where transmission was
shown to be occurring many times in
nightclubs gyms and other public spaces
until preventative measures could not
cook sorry could be reinforced at those
sites
and such precision and short-term
lockdowns demonstrated that unlike
influenza initial covid-19 outbreaks
could be contained and transmission
interrupted the same was true in
Singapore and South Korea in early
outbreaks that occurred in religious
institutions and nightclubs which is
what you've just told us many Asian
countries continued to keep transmission
at low levels before vaccines became
available by outbreak investigation and
precision lockdowns at the source
similar to those used in Japan
so as of the 19th of February 2023 Asian
countries had reported fewer covid-19
deaths per million in the population and
you there give the figures Japan
566 South Korea 680 Singapore
294 which are to be compared with Italy
the USA
3344 and the UK 3038
thereby attesting to the effectiveness
of their containment strategies though
other factors including the level of
comorbidities in obesity may have also
played a role so so thank you very much
those figures speak for themselves
really do they not
yes
um
yeah you have described when giving
evidence before today
what is known as a surgical lockdown
it is that the same as a Precision
lockdown simply a different way of
expressing the same that's correct all
right
um
what is your opinion of
the knowledge that the United Kingdom
could and perhaps should have had of the
effect that SARS and MERS had had in
those Asian countries and and how that
knowledge could or should have been used
in its pandemic planning
in pandemic planning the UK was very
strong in influenza yes that was what
their planning was mainly about because
in fact that was on the top of their the
risk register in the UK
so there was very much emphasis placed
on influenza and preparedness activities
were going on as we'll talk about
possibly later on preparedness though
doesn't just include strong Public
Health which is mainly the focus of many
other many of the preparedness plans it
also includes a surge capacity and
resilience of a health system to be able
to take care of patients who are
infected as well as patients who have
routine health issues and in addition
healthy populations are better to resist
serious illness after infection and
healthy populations include those with
fewer comorbidities
right so just taking us back for a
moment to the evidence that you've just
given about the preparedness of of those
Asian countries who had had
um a severe experience of SARS and MERS
um
is there anything about the lack of
information sharing that you've also
told us about that may have affected the
United Kingdom having the ability to to
find out and understand the way in which
those diseases had affected those
countries
I think the information was pretty well
available it wasn't available yet in
peer-reviewed
Publications because it takes a time to
get those out but it was being exchanged
within who within circles around the
world and I think most informal contacts
of Health were of Health Systems in
countries understood that this was quite
a serious outbreak in Asia especially
after the Diamond cruise ship event
where a patient from hunk or a person
from Hong Kong is thought to have
infected passengers on a cruise ship
right so does the
does the fact that the United Kingdom
didn't have
surgery capacity it didn't have
hospitals with ventilators and beds
awaiting a virus such as this and didn't
have a contact tracing system set up
indicate that that we hadn't learned
from the previous experience of those
Asian countries with SARS and Mars the
UK had quite a good case
contact tracing systems in fact they're
used at the local level regularly for
outbreaks that occur but they occur at
the local level where trust is very
important because if people are going to
give information about their contacts
they're going to give it to people who
they Trust so countries including the UK
centralized more of their contact
tracing activities and by so doing there
was a less less of a trust in that
contact tracing and it may be that it
was less effective and so the lesson
that I think we've all learned and we
all many of us knew and before is that
contact racing must be done where
there's trust and where you can interact
with people it can't be done digitally
in an effective manner all right what's
about the the lack of surge capacity in
hospitals the lack of surge capacity
after the influenza pandemic there was
an increase in hospital respirators as
far as I understand and there had been
practice in in activities related to
influenza but they were just not
activities that were with the current
pandemic and I'm not sure whether or not
I can't say whether or not they included
what might happen if capacity in
hospitals was over overwhelmed although
the UK responded rapidly with its units
that they did set up all right finally
but before we leave this topic please
could we display the report of exercise
Alice which is its inq
um zero zero zero zero two two seven
three two please and go to page five
I go to page 16 in fact
now exercise Alice is as you will know
Professor
um was an exercise a tabletop exercise
that was delivered on the 15th of
February of 2016 involving the
Department of Health as it then was NHS
England and public health England and it
was based around a large-scale outbreak
of MERS and dealt with two stages first
of all the initial actions of the local
health organizations and secondly a
position when the virus had spread to
white to a wider number of cases and and
what we can see here at page 16 of the
report as appendix a are the uh is the
summary of lessons and actions
identified and I'd like to highlight
please if we could number five action
number five
thank you
we can see that
recommended by those producing the
report was a briefing paper to be
produced on the South Korea outbreak of
MERS with details on the cases and
response and to consider the direct
application to the UK including Port of
Entry screening
now first of all do you consider that
that was a an appropriate lesson to
learn an action to to raise yes
do you know Professor Heyman whether or
not that briefing paper was ever
prepared I do not know all right thank
you very much we can put that away
please
predicting future pandemics
and this is something that we touched
upon yesterday in the evidence of
Professor Whitworth and Dr Hammer
um and they described to us the
phenomenon known as diseasex and and why
it's important for countries to expect
the unexpected or to
um look forwards and include in our
pandemic planning and a disease which is
not yet known about the the details of
which
um are not known about do you agree with
that yes and and can you explain to us
why you think it's important for that to
be part of a country's pandemic planning
if you look at a d disease X as being a
respiratory infection or a respiratory
disease and look at the various outcomes
of what might occur from that
respiratory infection
then you can begin to prepare based on
different scenarios it's not just one
scenario as we talked earlier it may be
a respiratory virus that produces deep
in the lungs it may be one that produces
superficially
but it's usually disease X in my view is
a respiratory infection but there are
other means of disease spread as you
know yes it can spread by enteric
infection infections food or water and
they can spread by vector-borne
mosquitoes and other insects so there
are many different ways in which
infections can be spread the disease X
to me is that rapid spread of an
infection
usually a respiratory infection
and what Professor Whitworth told us
yesterday was that in his opinion it's
important to have a generic plan in
place that can be adapted depending on
the specific
details of the of the disease that that
becomes a pandemic that that attacks us
if you like do you agree with that yes
as long as it can be adapted based on
the different
characteristics of known what we know
about viruses where they reproduce how
rapidly they transmit incubation periods
and a whole series of other issues
do you think that
that on the
severity of covid-19 could have been
predicted
I don't believe it could have been
predicted precisely no I believe that
there was concern about coronaviruses
that they could spread rapidly within
populations we had endemic coronaviruses
so I think there was concern about it
but it an outbreak such as this cannot
be precisely predicted because you can't
predict an outbreak based on only one
thing and that would be a virus it has
to be those risk factors that line up to
cause the emergence and because the
infection to spread
the human animal infections and risk
surveillance group known as hairs
um
tell us please Professor what that group
works on and and the the importance of
um the work that it does in terms of the
animal kingdom diseases there zoonosis
and the prediction of what might be
coming along the line the Harris group
is a one Health Group and one Health
means that the animal human and
environmental sectors are working
together on risk assessment risk
analysis and risk management it's a very
important mechanism within the UK UK was
one of the first countries to develop
such a mechanism so it's very important
and in addition it includes the devolved
administrations and it includes Ireland
the Republic of Ireland so it's a very
important way of looking doing Horizon
scanning looking what infections are
occurring in animals and what their risk
might be to human populations and cares
group meets it's it's it's the
environmental sector the government
sector of the human health sector and
the environmental sector meets once a
month
and they look at what's on the horizon
and they see whether or not that can be
considered as a risk in the UK and if
the UK is not prepared they recommend
guidelines they recommend doing things
to become better prepared and so it's a
very useful mechanism and hopefully what
it could do is shift the the Paradigm
from Rapid detection in response to
prevention at The Source by knowing the
source of where these infections might
come from and that's a very important
concept because today most countries
think well what we need is a rapid
detection system that will rapidly
respond what is needed is a one Health
environment where hopefully in the
future epidemics and pandemics can be
prevented
I can give an example yes please immerse
coronavirus we know that it's endemic in
camels yes we know that humans get
infected sporadically from time to time
from Camels
the obvious solution to this is to
develop a vaccine and use it in camels
as long as that prevents infection of
camels and prevents nasal Carriage of
the virus we can prevent future
outbreaks of Mercy coronavirus that's
why it's important to be looking at both
the animal and human sector in the
environmental sector at the same time
not at all so so prevention at source
meaning
the animal before the zoonosis occurs
before the disease jumps into humans
rather than the rapid detection and
response once that has happened both are
important but it's certainly the ideal
is to shift the Paradigm back to
prevention as the source thank you
um
let's then please move to your
conclusions and recommendations
um may we look first please at
recommendation one which is at page 55
in your report and each of your
recommendations is preceded by a
conclusion and in relation to
recommendation one
you have concluded that research needs
to be cutting edge that there needs to
make the UK needs to maintain its high
vaccination rate and if we can go to the
to the next paragraph please paragraph
um 262 we can see here your first
recommendation is this funding for
research should continue in order to
answer questions related to the pandemic
strategy adopted by the UK including
total population lockdowns and the
impact the strategy has had on sickness
and death and on surge capacity and
resilience to continue routine Health
Care funding should also be made
available for analysis of long-term
outcomes including better understanding
of long covert and other sequeling and
for better understanding of the impact
of pandemic control measures on Mental
Health on Youth and on industry and
business in the travel sector by joining
The Horizon Research program of the EU
in which the UK was a leader in the past
increased funding would become available
to supplement that provided nationally
so so that is what you are recommending
in relation to continued funding that's
correct the UK in fact has contributed
much much information to the literature
because of their excellent research
capacity and because of the funding that
was made available by ukri on the
rolling call for research that could be
completed within a period of 12 months
early on in the in the pandemic in fact
I chaired the panel that reviewed those
research proposals they were excellent
and they gave very important information
thank you can we move to paragraph 264
please which is recommendation to
thank you and before this you have said
um in your second conclusion that the
United Kingdom is one of the most
respected donors of international
activities to better prepare the world
for epidemics and pandemics and so your
recommendation here is that funding
should continue to be made available to
National academic and Technical experts
so that they are able to support
International activities that strengthen
epidemic and pandemic preparedness and
response activities including support
for funds at academic institutions and
within government that permit
replacement of skills nationally where
United Kingdom experts are responding to
overseas needs that official development
assistance support should also continue
to be provided both to public private
and other pandemic preparedness
activities as well as to International
organizations that provide Global
guidance and support epidemic and
pandemic prevention preparedness and
response capacity development that this
should include continued active
participation of the United Kingdom
government in negotiations around the
revised International Health regulations
and the pandemic treaty using its soft
diplomatic power when needed
do you do you stand by that
recommendation I stand by that
recommendation thank you moving to
paragraphs
266 please
um recommendation
three at 266 is to continue to make
permanent cross-government interaction
in activities that lead to Stronger
epidemic prevention preparedness and
response and identify means of including
the private sector in such activities by
ensuring that conflict of interest
whether perceived or real is understood
and respected in decision making and if
we could move to paragraph 268 and deal
with these together
you'll your fourth recommendation is
cross-government working in a one Health
mode which you've described to us a few
moments ago without seeding to the
temptation to create a separate one
Health Ministry or agency should be
formalized or permanent cross-government
work in a one Health mode for epidemic
prevention preparedness and response
should continue and include all economic
sectors both public and private so that
a shift can be made to prevention at the
source such a shift might be partially
accomplished for example by increased
use of cost-effective vaccines in humans
and animals cleaner Agriculture and
cross-sector Joint risk assessment
analysis and action
so taking those two recommendations
together
you are very much of the view Professor
are you not that not only should there
be cross-government work but also what
you've described as one Health work
within
um both the government and the public
and the private sector
um
without being tempted to create a one
Health Ministry or agency because that
would be effectively working in a silo
and what you are promoting is is is is
is working very much as a whole
yes in fact during the pandemic I had
the opportunity to see what many
different companies in the UK were doing
as their preventive and managed to
respond and also with the airline
industry because they contacted me
having had worked with them during the
SARS pandemic epidemics rather in 2003
and it was clear that they had many
Innovations which might have been useful
within the government had the government
included them in some of their
discussions and I think there was quite
a high level of frustration that they
had to work separately from the
government because of this fear of a
perceived conflict of interest so it's
it's always there that concern for
conflict of interest and it's very
important but I think there are ways
that lessons can be learned from the
private sector from others that can be
useful within government and vice versa
joined up thinking joined up thinking
not only across government but across
sectors thank you and finally
recommendation five at paragraph 270.
um you recognize in in your fifth
conclusion that some of the failures in
epidemic and pandemic preparedness could
have been prevented by focusing on
preparedness activities that include but
are not limited to the public health
system and he's there mentioned again
surge capacity within the NHS
so your recommendation five is to
increase the dhsc oversight of the
partnership between the government
agencies responsible for health
Improvement medical management and
health protection and public health with
a focus on better epidemic and pandemic
preparedness in the future yes
thank you very much my lady please could
you
um please could you grant permission for
Professor Hayman's report to be
published certainly
I'm just being given some instructions
while you read those instructions
um
when you spoke about hairs
I'm going to
a lot of these acronyms
um who established it is it a government
type organization is it a voluntary
organization amongst experts how is it
operated it's an organization among
experts my lady and it was established
by the health Protection Agency back in
the early 2000s as a means of bringing
together technical people within the
government and within the devolved
administrations in the Republic
Ireland
thank you my lady before I finish I'm
being invited to ask two follow-up
questions on advice in relation to the
wearing of masks and I'm happy so to do
with your permission
Professor Heyman um
can you explain why
um the experience of SARS and MERS both
being coronaviruses
um
may not have been sufficient evidence
for the World Health Organization to
have advised at the beginning of the
covid-19 outbreak that mask wearing was
a good precautionary
um element to take
well it's very difficult to set up a
study to determine the effectiveness of
that of mask wearing and there was great
confusion in the general public and in
fact in some governments about what mask
wearing was for wearing a mask was to
prevent others from being coming
becoming infected unless that mask also
included protective covering of the eyes
so mask wearing was a means of
preventing transmission to others from
the person who was infected it's very
difficult to set up a study to evaluate
that and collect evidence because it's
hard to know who's infected and so it
the evidence was not there and these
outbreaks were relatively small immersed
coronavirus and SARS coronavirus and
there weren't studies that were set up
to
evaluate that in Asia masks have been
worn as a courtesy when people are
infected for many many years and when a
person has a upper respiratory infection
many times they wear a mask to protect
others so it was much easier for them to
implement activities of mask wearing
because the population was accustomed to
it
downside to the World Health
Organization as a precaution once
covid-19 was beginning to spread
advising that that masks should be worn
there was one down there would have been
one downside and that is the fact that
medical masks were in very short supply
and if the general public were trying to
get these masks as well as the Health
Community it might cause a very serious
problem and so I know in the U.S after
the after an outbreak of a choir in
March of 2020 they recommended cloth
face coverings to prevent transmission
from a person infected to others so
there was concern I believe in many
circles including a who is by making a
recommendation to wear masks this would
compound the shortage which was
occurring from medical of medical masks
all right thank you very much that's
very clear
my lady I have now finished
as as my lady knows we have a procedure
in place during which core participants
are able to warn us of of questions or
areas of questions that they wish to ask
and I know that Alison Monroe King's
Council who is representing the covid
bereaved families for justice today for
the today's purposes wishes to ask one
question based around a topic which we
have been informed about so my lady
you've provisionally given an indication
that you would provide your permission
for that to be done May that now be done
thank you yes Miss Monroe thank you very
much
thank you
we're now the afternoon oh still morning
just good morning Professor Heyman my
name is Alison Monroe and I represent
the uh bereaved families for justice UK
and just one topic and one question and
one point of clarification arising out
of that topic which I'd like to ask you
and seek your assistance on please
it's the topic is the issue of
infectious disease strategy
and by way of a sort of point of
clarification in a general sense when
one thinks about or plans
uh strategy for infectious diseases
there would be a raft of different
components some more important than
others within such a strategy wouldn't
there yes and
this is not an exhaustive list at all
but by way of example some of those
components would be things such as good
public health and a good Public Health
System
clear consistent messaging high levels
of coordination
intra-governmentally and with the
scientific Community with health
communities early alertness of
infectious
diseases and a clear understanding of
where transmission
happened and an effective way of rapidly
stopping that and shutting that down
would you agree yes those are some of
the more important components thank you
within that context then
um professor
the question arises from
something that is said by somebody that
I think you're probably very well
acquainted with Professor Dame Jenny
Harris
who will in due course be giving
evidence to this inquiry but has
provided a written statement and a
number of exhibits my lady I don't
propose to take Professor Heyman to any
particular documents but simply for the
purposes of reference the um part of
Dame Jenny Harry's documents that I wish
to refer to are found at inq four zeros
90317 and it's an exhibit j h M1 treble
nut treble zero nine
now
she refers in that part of her statement
Professor to a document
quite an old one from 2002 called
getting ahead of the Curve
you're nodding there's a document you're
probably very familiar with
for those who are not by way of a very
very a bridge summary it's effectively
it was produced by the then chief
medical officer sir Ian Donaldson and it
recognized that the country faced a
number of public health challenges
including infect infectious diseases
um and it looked at ways of um dealing
with that you know recognized the need
to bring together skills and expertise
of a number of separate organizations to
work in a coordinated way
going back then to uh the question that
um is posed
Dame Jenny Harris says this
in her statement it's a paragraph of 106
for reference my lady
in 2018
on a national UK National level
Public Health England identified that
there'd been a gap in National strategy
across governments focusing on
infectious diseases and this Gap had
been apparent since 2002 and the getting
ahead of the curved document
having recognized this Gap work was then
started in 2018
to address that issue of a strategy for
infectious diseases and it was published
in the Autumn of 2019.
identifying 10 different strategies
including a strategy for infectious
diseases
um now I appreciate Professor Heyman
that you're not a person that makes
policy decisions or policies but are you
able to assist us at all in terms of why
there was that gap of um a period of
some 17 years 16 years where there was
no detailed
infectious disease strategy
I really can't answer that question it's
my understanding that there were several
plans on infectious disease prevention
and control which were developed I I
don't know what she's referring to that
was the Gap I I don't know I would need
to see what documents were prepared and
I can't answer your question I'm sorry
I'm very grateful my lady that's the
question thank you very much Miss Monroe
right and I think one of the next
Witnesses is attending yes
we need to rise very briefly please my
lady thank you very much thank you very
much indeed Professor Heyman not only
were you very helpful but we were very
clear too so thank you thank you very
much
let me know when you're ready thank you
foreign
please call Professor David Alexander
and Bruce Mann Professor Alexandra is
joining us from abroad by videoing
Professor Alexander I understand you've
recently undergone a bereavement I'm
very sorry
thank you very much I also have card
react problems I I do apologize most
profusely for not being present in
person totally understand thank you very
much
I swear by almighty God I swear by
almighty God that the evidence I shall
give that the evidence I shall give
shall be the truth shall be the truth
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
professor
yes I can okay
okay I do simonly sincerely
I do sovereign
that the evidence I shall give
but the evidence I shall give shall be
the truth
shall be the truth
the whole Ruth the whole truth and
nothing but the
fact and nothing but the truth
gentlemen could I commence my asking you
both to ensure that you keep your voices
up it's going to be a little difficult
at times
the first world example to hear you so
it's important that you do keep your
voice up
there are certain things about which
you're not clear please
uh ask for the question to be put again
um there will be a break at lunchtime
lunchtime our time uh and um there will
be a break during the course of the
afternoon as we proceed through your
evidence
thank you very much indeed for your
joint expert report weighing in I'm
proud to say at a hefty 321 pages
um could we have that please on the
screen it is
two zero three three four nine
[Applause]
and my lady may we have your permission
to have that reports published
at page two of the report
we see something in short order of your
professional qualifications
Professor Alexander commencing with you
please first are you
professor of risk and disaster reduction
at University College London
from 1982 until 2002 did
in the fields of geomorphology physical
geography natural Hazard and disaster
studies at the University of
Massachusetts in the United States of
America
were you also scientific directory
Advanced School of civil protection of
the regional government of Lombardy and
also professor at the University of
Florence
it is correct you published the book
natural disasters it was published in
London and New York in 1983 it's been
subsequently reprinted and you've
published a number of subsequent books
and articles including how to write an
emergency plan
that's correct and where you were are
you still vice president and chairman of
the trustees of The Institute of civil
protection and Emergency Management I I
am Mr man turning to you from 1979 to
2016 were you a member of the United
Kingdom Civil Service serving in the
ministry of defense and the cabinet
office
that is correct your mod roles included
being head of the nuclear accident
response organization director of
defense policy and mod roles in the
Falklands Gulf and Kosovo conflict most
relevantly for our purposes did your
cabinet office experience include
serving in the cabinet secretary dealing
with terrorism and Cold War planning
then subsequently being director of the
Civil contingencies Secretariat from
2004 to 2009. that is correct and were
you also the leader of the independent
review of the Civil contingencies act in
its supporting Arrangements 2022
I was
itself also a weighty tone
do you and have you both confirmed that
the report which you've very kindly
provided for us is the product of your
own work that the facts stated in it are
within your own knowledge and you
understand your duty to provide
independent evidence and expertise
yes thank you yes
now
it's probably convenient to start by
considering very briefly the scope of
your report could we please have at page
there we are Annex a scope of the report
who set out there
the matters that you were asked to
address by this inquiry and in very
broad terms
were you asked to consider the overall
approach to risk Emergency Management
and a number of issues relating to that
broad topic
pandemic preparedness
in particular whether they were in place
suitable arrangements for identifying
and assessing the risk of a
non-influenza pandemic such as a
coronavirus pandemic
whether or not there was an effective
approach to building whole system
preparedness
the extent to which lessons had been
learned from other countries by which
we've just heard Professor him give
evidence
and whether again in particular
overall pandemic preparedness and
resilience Arrangements properly
highlighted in the United Kingdom the
the ant prepared for the cascading
consequences of a pandemic
so in in truth a very wide scope indeed
um
could you please have up on the screen
page nine
[Applause]
you commence your report by setting out
as we've just seen the matches which you
were asked to address and
at page nine
the sections into which you've divided
your response and and the way that
you've done it is this is that you set
out in section two the Strategic
approach adopted by successive UK
governments you addressed in section
three the key preparedness structures
sections 456 over the page
were the key preparedness structures and
supporting Arrangements adequate
and then most importantly perhaps for
the purposes of today laterally in your
report you addressed the broad area of
pandemic preparedness before bringing
all that together and and providing a
very long list of conclusions and
recommendations
is that right Mr Man it is
in the first part of your report
we don't need I think to get it up on
the screen
make this point
more reports on generic or pandemic
preparedness are published every week
there are hundreds of recommendations
made but we are conscious inquiries set
yourself the goal of reporting quickly
and one of the reasons why that is a
desirable aim Mr Man is that
lessons may be learned as soon as
practicable
what is his position of the United
Kingdom government what is its judgment
in relation to potential
future frequency of infectious disease
outbreaks
I think there are two key points from
documents published by the government I
wouldn't say that they address the
question of frequency
I think the two key points are as
follows and I'll quote from those
documents first
that infectious disease outbreaks are
likely to be more frequent by 2030
and second
that another novel pandemic
remains a realistic possibility
that is in the so-called integrated
review of Defense security and
resilience that was published in 2021
so at a very Broad and provisional and
and
um necessary in introductory approach
is it generally well recognized then
that there is now a greater and even
greater need to inquire into these
issues to
report
and to learn lessons in the field of
disease outbreaks
I I hope that it is recognized I
recognize these statements here but
clearly they need to be followed through
into action
I'm so priced that the government bet
that
another novel pandemic remains a
realistic possibility I would have
thought a better way of describing
describing it is as an inevitability
given that if we look at history
pandemics have been recurrent throughout
recorded human history
a great deal a large part of your report
what Professor Alexandra and Mr Mann
sets out
very detailed
quite prescriptive views on
aspects of the United Kingdom
system for preparedness resilience and
response
and at the beginning of your report
therefore you you've set out some of the
features of the way in which you've gone
about trying to identify the most
important points and you've set out some
some generic points about the way in
which you've approached your exercise
and how
Milady and this inquiry should go about
considering the general field of
preparedness in in the context of our
emergency civil emergency procedures so
may I turn to just trying to highlight
some of the general points that you've
made in in your report
first point you make and it's at page 12
paragraphs 12 and 13 of your report
is that you say that it's very important
to note and to acknowledge
that
on account of the planning undoubtedly
necessary and worthwhile planning that
was done for the the potential No Deal
uh exit from the European Union
the inevitable consequence of the
devotion of time and energy to No Deal
planning had an impact
on the United Kingdom's procedures and
systems for General civil emergency
preparedness is that right
yes that is right
get is that a political point that you
see to make or is it simply a statement
of fact
that in preparing for one thing which
was a necessary aim in itself the
preparation had to be done there was
inevitably going to be consequences on
other areas from which government
resources time and effort weren't then
going to be diverted
no let me be clear it is not a political
point it is an administrative point
yes of course
there was an absolute need to prepare
for exit from the European Union
the point that we seek to make is that
as well as preparing for if you came to
it an odia exit
they should have been capacity made
available
to continue to pursue preparedness
planning in other fields
the position of the United Kingdom
government
that
in fact
important work was done
in the course of preparing for the No
Deal exit
for example in relation to the
reinforcement of
proprietary relationships and links
between various entities in relation to
solidifying and and better preparing
Supply chains in relation to the
training of civil servants
because of course they would have to be
trained for the purposes of ensuring for
all the worst aspects that could come
from a unintended
No Deal exit in terms of our
preparedness structures and therefore
there were undoubtedly benefits
which accrued as a result of of the
attention to that particular course
yes I recognize those benefits
in exactly the two ways you describe
which
appear in the witness statements which
we read
on Supply chains and on
the ability the Improvement in the
capability to manage major emergencies
crises which but at page 11 do you
nevertheless identify that important
work in the field of civil emergency
including work on Health Care provision
adult social care resilience and
critical sectors planning for the use of
the police in the military the design of
the central response structures
refreshing the 2011 pandemic
preparedness strategy and refreshing the
UK pandemic influenza communication
strategy
was affected to some degree or another
yes
great
that deals with in a very general sense
the United Kingdom government were there
consequences also in relation to
specifically Wales Scotland and Northern
Ireland
yes I think the witness statements bring
the consequences in each Administration
bring this out very clearly page 12
please
so in relation to Wales
so in relation to Wales in the same way
as
in my view important aspects of public
facing preparedness as opposed to
Whitehall facing preparedness
important aspects of public facing
preparedness have to be paused
there were benefits in Northern Ireland
and the witness statements make that
very clear those are again focused on
although it is important they are
focused on the the inward facing within
the administration capabilities
in relation to Scotland
which I think is over the page
was there an impact insofar as
the bi-annual every two year that this
every two years the binal report to
Scottish ministers provide an overview
of the resilience of essential services
and critical infrastructure were not
published
yes this is the third aspect of that
there were in this analysis we broke
the impact down into three areas the
first is preparing us within an
Administration
the second is the Assurance which
ministers and Senior officials could
take on preparedness and this paragraph
covers exactly that and then the public
facing activity preparing for
the inevitable consequences of a severe
pandemic
in fact in the witness statements there
is a clear threat of a common feeling
that there were areas in which
responsibilities were not adequately
clarified between central government and
between the devolved Administration
and Professor Alexander when you say in
the witness statements are you in fact
referring to witness statements which
have been obtained by the inquiry from
United Kingdom government civil servants
and employees I'm specifically referring
to exactly those but from members of the
developed administrations but also
Northern Ireland
just frequent Mr man could you just
expand a little on what you meant by
Whitehall facing and public facing
by Whitehall facing I mean the
preparedness within a government
department or series of government
departments so more trained staff better
facilities and so on
it is all excellent
but it doesn't address the fact that
preparedness for
plans and preparedness
for issues that would affect the public
who would be affected by a major
emergency were paused
thank you
in relation to Northern Ireland
you say at the top of that page if we
still have it page 13
by contrast for the Northern Ireland
executive EU exit planning was broadly
beneficial in building generic
resilience and preparedness although
some matters will pause for other
reasons the assessment of the official
most Eclipse involved was an EU exit
planning meant that Northern Ireland was
in a better position to to manage the
demands of major emergencies
and is that in fact a reference to
evidence obtained by the inquiry from
the permanent secretary to the executive
office in Northern Ireland who provides
a corporate statement which sets out the
executive officer's view of the impact
of the diversion of resources and
attention to EU exit but concluded that
broadly that planning was was beneficial
as far as Northern Ireland was concerned
in exactly the same space this is within
the executive
you refer on the following page to the
overall Judgment of a gentleman called
Sir David Sterling who I think was the
head of the northern Irish Civil Service
which in 2017 and 2020.
he says at paragraph 16 of your report
because you've cited a segment of his
evidence
three challenges a persistent political
instability resource pressures and
brexit were significant issues in their
own right together they combined combine
to create a complex and difficult
context and significant resource
pressures
so in relation to Northern Ireland
having reviewed the material from the
northern Irish executive office as well
as other civil servants in Northern
Ireland
have you noted that whilst
the attention paid to a No Deal exit had
some beneficial impacts the position in
Northern Ireland
what was a different one because of the
issue concerning the collapse and the
power sharing agreement and what sir
David calls political instability
yes we tried to describe on the basis I
suspect of relatively limited evidence
the three
issues which facing Northern Ireland
we try to bring out one key judgment
which is that in March 2020 on the basis
of the administrative issues inside
Northern Ireland
a number of new and experienced staff
had to be brought in at the very
beginning of the response to the
pandemic
all right thank you very much that is
the first point that I wanted to draw
your attention to in a very in a wide
and generic way
the second point that you make in your
report in in a general sense is
the the need to look to the Future
um
when asked to prepare recommendations
and and improvements in the way that you
have
is it necessary to try to form a view or
to try to look as far into the future as
you can so that whatever you recommend
if my lady adopts those recommendations
and builds on them for herself
that those recommendations will will
stand the test of time and will have as
as long
term
an impact is possible
yes
um
just in a very general sense perhaps
Professor Alexander
where do we stand in the general scheme
of things in terms of the United
Kingdom's preparedness structures when
were they last
subject to radical review
I suppose really that the last
very significant change was the
construction and the passing of the
Civil contingencies act in 2004 which
removed the need to depend upon
thoroughly outdated legislation from the
Cold War and the civil defense period
that at least established statutory
duties not merely among government but
among the providers of essential
services
uh in my view it didn't go far enough
but I think that is also the view of the
independent review of the Civil
contingencies Act
but we also have the fact that these
civil contingencies act good or bad as
it might be was essentially thrown out
of the window during covid in other
words it was essentially replaced by the
coronavirus act which although it was
drafted in 2017
was essentially passed very quickly with
little debate once the pandemic had
started
or I will return to the question of the
pandemic draft bill and the Korean virus
act in due course
and when as you say the Civil
contingencies Act was passed in 2004 had
the the passage of that bill and and the
it it's coming into Force
um come after a time when the government
had been dealing with matters such as
widespread flooding I think foot and
mouth that there had been fuel protests
in the Years or at least at some point
in the in the two or three years before
the ACT
was that
primary legislative structure and the
duties which were associated with it and
the guidance and so on
to what extent were they informed by the
political events that had taken place in
United Kingdom in the run-up
the 2004. I think they very much were
and if you look at the world scale you
tend to find that about three-quarters
of legislation on disasters and how to
cope with them follows the event
now that may well be because disaster
events are very common worldwide we have
about 700 a year but nevertheless it is
extremely common for a major event a
major civil contingency to be the
stimulus or a reappraisal leading to the
passage of legislation to improve safety
have has there been a significant change
Mr Man in the
what you would describe as the risk
drivers
which currently bear on the United
Kingdom in in terms of the risks that
the country faces the its future
has the need to have a proper and
effective system in place changed on
account of changes in those risk drivers
yes I think there are two points here
first
the act on the legislation so the act
and its supporting Arrangements
were taken through actually before the
availability of the first national risk
assessment
and there was a realization
and this was in my time in post
there was a realization with the
national risk assessment of progressive
realization that some of those risks
were National or indeed International in
scale
and the arrangements we had in place
started with indeed the ACT has on the
face of the ACT local
Arrangements
that's the first point the second point
as we have developed as a society
technologically
not only within the UK but also
internationally over the course of the
last 20 years
those fundamental drivers you have heard
some evidence on this in terms of
urbanization population concentration
speed
and frequency with which people travel
technological developments and so on
means that the position now is it might
be fundamentally different to that in
2004.
so the risks that you've described
appear to be more uncertain
they are of perhaps greater complexity
greater frequency
is there also a greater risk now of what
you describe as the cascading events
that is to say
that the coming together of different
risks simultaneously to create an even
more complex emergency or of an
emergency developing in unexpected ways
so that other areas are then open to to
crisis
yes Professor Alexander has written the
book on this I'll turn to him professor
perhaps but we'll hear from you on that
I I have a research group on cascading
disasters and we would argue that all
major civil contingencies and many minor
ones are cascading events by their very
nature because we live in networked
societies which require us to interact
in certain ways that can be easily
disrupted by such impacts so we're not
only dealing with cascading events where
you have to begin with the toppling
Domino's
metaphor where One Thing One impact
leads to another we also have escalation
points in that where the interaction of
different kinds of vulnerability can
cause a worse secondary impact to the
one that started off the whole process
on certain occasions but apart from all
of that we have the possibility ability
of concurrent events although this is
not directly relevant to the UK during
covid there were three major earthquakes
around the world they required a very
different way of dealing with the event
to that required for dealing with an
infectious disease and yet it had to
take place simultaneously I think the UK
in this was lucky quite simply lucky
that it didn't have for example major
flooding or something like that during
covid because they could easily have any
large natural Hazard impact or something
else that would have even further
complicated the response required thank
you
the third General point that you make in
in your introduction is that
future improvements and changes
significant changes to the the
structural system for emergency
preparedness response and resilience
must reflect better
than perhaps they have in the past
societal and public expectation what did
you mean by that
I meant that there is a range of
societal factors we list them in the
report
which
any preparedness structure any law any
Arrangements have got to take into
account
they are built to protect people they
are built in the name of the people
and they've got to be embedded it's not
just about processes and law and
structures and so on
it's got to have a human face to it
we've identified five in the report of
which in our view the most fundamental
is competence
I'm happy to go through the others if
you wish well we'll get to the
conclusions in due course you you've
separated out your conclusions by
reference to these to some of these
generic points
um may I may I add please but I think
the UK is very good at foresight in 2011
to 12 there is a major foresight program
regarding civil contingencies and there
is now another and it is turning up some
very interesting pictures of what the
country is now facing and will probably
be facing over the next 50 years the
question however Remains the extent to
which the results of such exercises are
taken into account in the arrangements
for dealing with events and that is a
very different matter
so are you saying then Professor that
whilst
as a country and and on the part of its
various institutions that there is good
thinking going on in relation
to the possibility of future risks what
they may consist of and what challenges
we as a country will face
the trick is to ensure that what
arrangements are put into place to give
effect to that foresight reflect public
trust reflect public confidence ensure
that we as a country have faith in those
arrangements and therefore more likely
to to comply with them and to follow
follow them is is that the issue
yes indeed I think the bottom line of
all of this is do you think that the
British government within the limits of
its competency keeps the public safe I
fear my answer to that is no or not
sufficiently currently
um we have a very quick illustration of
this um we have these foresight programs
that have indicated what the hazards are
but we also have
um scenario building exercises in
government namely the national risk
register and the National Security risk
assessment which have very short time
Horizons and yet we know very well that
many of the contingencies we Face are
going to change and grow in the short
term the medium and the long term
and they will require adaptation to them
and and
may we take it from what you've said
Professor that that's your view of the
of the current position
that currently the structures that we
have in place do not keep us safe or do
not keep us as safe as you would wish
and everybody would sensibly wish us to
be is is that your view that is indeed
true we are of course all responsible
for our own safety but government of
course has an essential fundamental and
Central role in providing safety to its
population and I think it could do more
and better in that
all right while we will return of course
to some of the aspects to which you've
made reference particularly the National
Security risk assessment in in due
course
the fourth General point that you raise
and to which you refer is is devolution
and this is an important point because
of course this is a United Kingdom
inquiry and it is inquiring of course
not just into Arrangements in
Westminster the United Kingdom
Arrangements but but into the Affairs of
England Scotland Wells and Northern
Ireland
in a general sense
who or which structures bear the primary
responsibility for dealing with
resilience dealing with preparedness
that is to say being in a position to
respond and resilience having the
ability or capacity to be able to
respond well
I'm sorry if I appear to be avoiding the
question it has to be a shared
responsibility
but technically and in law
civil contingencies is devolved
in Scotland and Wales
there are particular Arrangements
affecting Northern Ireland
so does it follow Professor please yes
yes thank you
um I I agree entirely with what Mr man
says
um however I think if you look around
the world you would see that the
management of civil contingencies only
works if it is done at the local level
because that is invariably no matter
what the size of the event the theater
of operations therefore the quality of
local organization is absolutely
Paramount it is however dependent on the
quality of support given by higher
levels of government one of the problems
we have in Britain is that if we leave
aside the question of the devolved
administrations we don't have an
intermediate tier to manage this and at
the same time it is very hard to manage
local Endeavors from Westminster
thank you does it follow therefore from
what you've you've both said that
proper and sensible recommendations must
take into account the need
to to bring about improvements not just
in the National structures but obviously
the devolve structures and local
structures because all play their part
in the overall system of preparedness
and resilience
yes it does I fear that we are attacking
back to your spaghetti diagram
eventually
but yes there are a wide range of
organizations involved in preparedness
and response
that means there's a wide range of
interfaces between those organizations
and all of that has got to fit together
smoothly
the fifth Point concerns
the difference between resilience and
preparedness before you go on to that Mr
Keith I think I'm being honest
I think that's an excellent time to
pause
forgive me um Professor Alexander I hope
you've got Arrangements where you can
get some money Mr Man thank you both
very much see you at quarter to two
right
foreign
Mr Man Professor Alexander you
referred repeatedly to the concept of
preparedness
and also to the concept of resilience
and we've all referred to those two
words
repeatedly already
preparedness appears to be about being
ready identifying a risk
the risk of an event occurring and then
preparing to deal with it so doing
something about it
resilience appears to us to relate to
capacity and concern
the ability to resist absorb or
adapt to an event
to what extent can
improvements to the structures for civil
emergency
better prepare us
as opposed to
better enable us to be resilient so
putting it another way
to what extent can any recommendation or
any inquiry improve our resilience
is that something which is capable of
being
reported on commented on being made the
subject of improvement
yes I think in three areas
first
on preventative activity
not only before an emergency arises
and you heard from Professor Heyman this
morning
but secondly at the onset of an
emergency to seek to slow spread
to give people time to prepare
that's the first area the second area
is to recognize
the need for whole system preparedness
third area is the need I'm sorry to use
jargon
to recognize the need for whole of
society preparedness that's not just
public sector entities
that is the volunteer community sector
the business sector communities
individuals and their families
thank you
a primary type here
all right
there is a question of Lessons Learned
which is a phrase that is often
exercised
the measure of a lesson learned is in
fact in measurable positive change there
are most definitely lessons to be
learned from covid-19 as there are from
previous events but one small
illustration of this situation is that
one of the lessons of the 2005 bombs in
London was the need for greater
coordination between the Emergency
Services particularly in the Declaration
of major incidents that moves them from
normal activity into fully emergency
related activity that had not happened
then
12 years later in the Manchester Arena
bombing there was exactly the same
problem which implied that in the 12
years that intervened that particular
lesson which is extremely important in
terms of saving lives had not been
learned
does it follow from what you both said
that the distinction for our purposes
between preparedness and resilience May
therefore matter little
because what matters is ensuring that
the country
puts itself in in a as best a position
as possible in order
to prevent civil emergency to respond to
civil emergency and to recover from
civil emergency
and and to do so in a way which engages
the whole system and the whole of
society and and so Notions of resilience
and
debate about how wealthy and healthier
country we are and how well we can adapt
to an emergency perhaps doesn't take us
very much further forward
I think if you're looking at risk
before an emergency happens
I think there are a variety of ways in
which you can tackle risk they we set
them out on figure one and figure two
which is identified in the first place
seek to avoid it or minimize its
consequences prepare for it respond to
it each of those is a separate and
distinct activity although there are
some overlaps but they all need to be
addressed for a country to be resilient
that's the proposition that we've got in
section two of our report so is
resilience just an Omnibus word then or
an aspect if you like of General
preparedness
preparedness is one aspect of resilience
but there are many others which need to
be addressed
all right
which is a concept that actually has a
history that goes back about 2018 years
for the first known sources of it it is
a rather difficult concept because it
has been used in at least 200 different
ways in modern times which can easily
confuse matters but to me it is a
mixture of adaptation and resistance
to Adverse Events this very definitely
includes preparedness and planning
therefore of preparedness and resilience
involve foresight because it is
necessary as far as possible
to anticipate the events that are likely
to occur where these can be foreseen
obviously not everything can be but very
much indeed can be you may be familiar
with the concept of the Black Swan as
um enunciated by Nicolas tab in his book
of that name it is worth remembering
that it is a concept that is quite
controversial in other words it applies
in economics which is a rather
distinctive discipline the idea is that
Europeans went to Australia believing
all swans were white and then
encountered black swans in other words
that we are likely to be faced by
analogy with events that are completely
unforeseeable and therefore unforeseen
but I think is not the case in terms of
civil contingencies just about
everything as precedence even though the
exact mix and the exact composition of
the event cannot be precisely predicted
but it trust me that planning is
absolutely fundamental and Central
thank you that that's very clear
the next era I wanted to touch upon with
you please is is
distinction between structures and
policy and operational response
very little of your report addresses the
detail of how for example services and
help are actually provided by way of
education or the responses of the
emergency services or the actual
provision of Health Care in hospitals or
or of social care and Care Homes
is that because when looking at a system
of preparedness and looking to see where
it can be improved it's necessary to
focus on the structures and on the
general policies rather than on the
specifics of operational responses
no I'd recommend it another way
the focus should be on the outcomes
what you're seek what are you seeking to
do to reduce harm and loss
at all stages that we're described in
the cycle
from there you can work back to how best
you bring the organizations that are
needed to reduce hormone loss together
and that means structures but it means a
lot else
into a partnership to reduce harm and
loss and of course policies and
practices are part of that mix I think
we may be across purposes does your
report seek to provide the detail of how
operationally responders and that may
include Emergency Services the NHS
educational facilities and cares and so
on should actually be responding day in
day out to an emergency no right our aim
as we say right at the beginning is to
address these strategic issues on the
basis that other modules will address
the more operational issues thank you
the next area concerns risk and you've
touched upon this already
um
are you agreed that
not all major risks to a country can be
identified in advance and of course not
all specific
major or catastrophic events can be
planned for
and is it as a result of that
that as as you say
no country can prepare for the specifics
of whatever emergency May ensue
the need is to identify in Broad terms
the risks
and to be able to plan for those broad
risks in a way that is sufficiently
flexible so that you can therefore
respond properly to whatever emergency
ensues
not quite
I agree with Professor Alexander that
actually most risks can be foreseen
in some shape or form ah but it is
inevitable two things are inevitable
first
human beings kind of being fallible that
not all risks will have been identified
we have been surprised in the UK on a
number of occasions
second the risk will not turn out the
way in which you thought it might turn
out
at that stage then you rely on the
planning that has been done for the risk
that have been identified
and on generic preparedness
and we're planning for all risks in the
way in which you've described
secondly however I would say best
practice is that for the most
significant risks the risks with the
highest likelihood and the highest
impact
there should be dedicated specific
emergency planning for those risks
before I Turn to You can I ask a
follow-up question please of Mr mans
that we can understand that the
parameters of this debate
the you you use the words in some shape
or form
the current system of preparers the
United Kingdom rests on the premise that
in Broad terms
categories of risk are identified
not the specific
risk which might eventuate a broad
category of risk of I don't know
flooding or
pandemic influenza or a new and emerging
disease
and those risks are then assessed in
terms of likelihood and impact and
assumptions are made as to the
consequences planning assumption is made
and then those assumptions are
disseminated so that everyone knows what
they're planning for
what they have to deal with and in
particular
what the reasonable worst case scenario
might be
so the starting point is
as you say not every single specific
risk is identified in its detail
so for both of you would you agree that
it is not possible
or perhaps you may say it is possible
but
have you not to say so that that every
single specific risk in its with its
particular detail can be identified in
advance
I think the distinction between us is
I believe that those risks can be
identified in advance the question is
what is taken into planning
so it is
there are thousands of risks confronting
the UK you cannot plan for thousands of
risks you need to group them together
where that is sensible to do so flooding
is an example you cannot predict
how where the flooding will be how
severe the flooding will be but what
you're going to do is build something
which says if there is flooding
this is the plan we'll put into place
that is the capabilities we will deploy
so I think there's a distinction between
us on identifying the risks in the first
place because if you don't do that you
will get called out I think we may be
across purposes Professor what do you
have to say to that proposition
think one of the key issues is building
scenarios there is a website from a
European project that was managed by the
University of Manchester and the website
is still active though the project is
finished which includes 1500 risks that
Europe and in particular the UK faces in
terms of a brief description of possible
scenarios and a description of so-called
weak signals which are indications that
that particular risk might be coming to
the fore now whether or not that helps
us is a moot point but let's also
remember that the National Security risk
assessment and the national risk
register is public face both include
scenarios I think however there are
severe or serious significant weaknesses
in both documents methodologically
speaking the key one perhaps is that the
scenarios don't connect directly to the
plans they are advisory for those who
are making plans but I am used instead
2-8 situation in which the scenario is
part of the plan the plan response to
this scenario and the scenario includes
the provisions for responding to the
event
there are other weaknesses including
short-term Horizons spurious
accuracy and some questionable
assumptions or failure to declare all
assumptions but nevertheless there is
this methodology and it does prioritize
the risks and let's remember that since
2008 viral pandemics were considered to
be the most likely and the most serious
among about 36 risks which figured in
both documents
perhaps we can descend
to the detail immediately
the the current system under the the
National Security risk assessment and
its public facing National risk register
identifies or at least in 2019 and we're
more concerned with the position as it
was when the pandemic struck
pandemic influenza and new emerging
disease in new emerging pathogen
we've heard evidence and it's obvious
that a reference to a new and emerging
disease doesn't tell you whether or not
that disease is asymptomatic or
symptomatic it doesn't tell you what its
incubation period is likely to be
it doesn't say anything about the
severity
and therefore the characteristics of
that particular risk remain unknown
are you saying that and we're
particularly concerned of course with
pandemic planning
that a sensible system of risk
assessment should be much more detailed
in its identification of the risk than
the current system so that their system
of
identifying broad risks flooding
pandemic influenza new and emerging
virus
is is too broad whilst it provides us
with flexibility it fails to make us
focus on the particular characteristics
of the risk and therefore prepare
I think there is sorry Mr man could you
because you nodded could you say yes and
so your answer is no that's good that
meant I understand your question Mr
Keith
I let Professor Alexander go first
thank you
um I think
there are various criticisms that can be
and have been leveled against the
methodology used in the UK for example
there are focal six major criticisms in
the assessment made by the rural Academy
of engineering of the National Security
risk assessment procedure I agree with
all of them but I would go a little
further than that one of the problems
also is that there is a failure in the
scenarios to be sufficiently inclusive
uh their experience accuracy but at the
same time there is a failure to consider
how things might develop in
specific particular cases but it can be
done on the 12th of October 2008 I
attended a Red Cross Symposium and at it
an epidemiologist stood up and gave a
45-minute lecture he started by saying
my job is to tell you something you
don't want to know and ask you to spend
money you haven't got on something you
don't think will happen he then went on
to describe a viral pandemic and let's
remember that this is half a medical
problem and an epidemiological problem
and half a socioeconomic problem
and he described all of that in
considerable detail it got me teaching
pandemics for the next 10 years and
trying to encourage the creation of
pandemic emergency plans it was also
quite clear that this was going to
happen and that large elements of it
were entirely predictable once the
pandemic in terms of infectivity and
lethality
asked a certain Tipping Point or reached
a certain level
all right
Mr man do you want to comment you uh you
deferred to Professor Alexander there no
I absolutely agree with what Professor
Alexander says there is a greater degree
of specificity that can be done right
the only thing that needs to be avoided
is that there are a thousand plans there
has to be some kind of aggregation to
make the task manageable but I do agree
with these exact points that were made
by Professor Alexander but the proof of
the pudding of course would have been
eating I mean you require further
specificity but you must still
acknowledge
that the system has to work and take
account of broad categories of risk the
the issue will be where do you draw the
line
yes which has to be a matter of judgment
but
a plan for
as David has said a plan for a severe
pandemic
has a lot of very common very
predictable features which ought to be
identified
and plan for specifically and are you
saying that they those characteristics
should have been identified in the
general risk assessment preparedness
procedures but weren't and the work that
followed up from there yes absolutely
well we'll look at that a minute later
if I might add to that very briefly
um one problem with the methodology that
is used in Britain is that it is utterly
specific in other words there is a
scenario for a pandemic I believe the
correct methodology would be to have an
envelope or a suite of scenarios this is
the best case this is the worst case
this is the median case what instead we
have uh is an algorithm that gives us
exact predictions 48
324 deaths will occur uh this of course
is nonsense it is indicative and in that
sense it is helpful but I think we need
a much broader way of describing our
scenario
all right well we're going to return to
that in in detail as later
um and and this broad level
where we must try to uh I'm afraid keep
our answers as short as we can or you
must keep an artist George you can if
we're to be able to get to the the meat
of it another broad point that you make
in in your report or you another issue
you refer to in your report is the
um the existence of international
indices of of Health security and
related capability and referred evidence
about the joint external evaluation
which is conducted under the
awesomenesses of the World Health
Organization and we've had alsoever a
second procedure under the global Health
security index processes
I'm in just in a in a general sense
and
is it possible accurately to gauge or
assess preparedness in advance of a
crisis
Britain United Kingdom did did well in
in the je evaluation prior to the
pandemic but the evidence may show that
in the reality we we didn't do so well
is it ever possible to gauge or assess
preparedness in advance yes I believe it
is provided that it is done in
sufficient detail against precise or
reasonably precise metrics yes I believe
that it is all right
now sorry Professor please yes please
add what you're going to add
um I have done research on this in
Mexico and of much dependence upon the
quality of the methodology used for
evaluation
um it did appear at the time of the
pandemic that the World Health
Organization evaluation of Britain's
ability to cope with the pandemic was
simply wrong
it didn't match up to the results that
came out in comparing the British
response to that of other countries or
comparable countries
all right thank you
um could you please turn to page 23 of
the report
Professor I presume you have a hard copy
of your report there I do in front of
you thank you
you say this
there was thus no document which set
direction for the wide range of
organizations involved in building
resilience preparedness helping to unify
their actions towards a common end
um
are you saying that there is in in the
United Kingdom no
no single document no single strategy no
single piece of paper which sets out our
disaster risk reduction strategy or is
is this a conceptual point that you're
making no no absolutely not very
practical point no there is no document
that sets out where we're trying to get
to how we'll know when you get there and
what steps we will take along the way
and importantly uh what resources we
will apply to trying to achieve that
ambition
that when finally an attempt is made of
this with the UK government resilience
framework of December 2022 in it there
is no mention of gender of people with
disabilities of the elderly or of ethnic
and cultural minorities and yet all of
these are essential issues that need to
be dealt with if resilience is to be
created maintained and guaranteed or
whatever
can we just pause for a moment then you
you've introduced a new and important
document is this the document
published by the United Kingdom
government in December 2022 I'm going to
hold it up professors that you can see
it the UK government resilience
framework exactly could we please have
um
Mr Mann and Professor Alexander um I
think the position was this was that uh
as a result of wider ranging
uh reviews carried out by by the
government
International Security and
biological security and integrated
reviews and so on and so forth that the
government committed to publishing a a
new strategy and it called for evidence
in July 2021 for uh
the public to contribute answers to
questions that it posed on a range of
topics and
um this document the re the resilience
framework was published in December 2022
and I don't want to spend time going
through it in detail with you because in
fact my lady Witnesses from the cabin
office will be addressing the particular
document later in in module one but
does it uh did it essentially set out an
action plan from the government in
relation to a number of areas risk
responsibilities and accountability
Partnerships communities investment and
skills
and set out a broad framework of
and I apologize for using this word it
is not my word deliverables
which would be
produced or which the government would
Endeavor to produce by reference to
um two deadlines
preparation and and conduct of actions
by 2025 and also the um production of
actions and deliverables by a later date
2030.
yes it did
in general terms
have you been able to take account of
that document the UK resilience
framework
for the purposes of producing from a
lady the report that you have yes at
relevant sections of our report we try
to intervene the relevant
points inside the government's
resilience framework
that that is
on on one view a strategy document it
sets out at a very high level what the
United Kingdom proposes to do in
relation to improving the structures
producing deliverables in relation to
various aspects of the civil emergency
structures in this country but why does
that not suffice to be the single
strategy document of which you speak
Four Points I think first
in my view it starts from the wrong
place
why it
sets out a range of measures and says if
those implies if those measures are
taken
we will have a sufficiently adequate
system to deal with the future we face
I don't believe that to be the case I
think the document should have started
in a different place
what do we need first to deal with
catastrophic emergencies
secondly actually to pick up
International best practice and I think
it falls short in both of those areas
second it's too slow
it suggests
a range of measures for implementation
in the period 2025 to 2030.
I think a lot of those can be done
sooner and ideally should be done sooner
food is not a strategy it was advertised
as a strategy he does not set out this
is where this is where we'd like to get
to this is how we'll know we'll get
there and these are the steps we'll take
on the way there's a lot of very good
ideas in there but they're not brought
together into single unifying roadmap
which everybody in the responded
Community can use and finally it is
almost silent on resourcing
Mr man you're probably more used to the
use of language of this kind than I am
fortunately
what exactly is the preparation of
conduct of actions mean it's not even
English is it
preparation of conduct does that mean
just actions
no it doesn't my lady
um it is very very I don't want to say
I'm so Humphrey about this but it's very
very carefully drafted language uh which
um uh includes
tries to seek to
um
buy time
and to leave open the option of not
proceeding with those proposed actions
but doesn't the word conduct usually
it ought to yes
yes but I don't think in this specific
case it is being used in that sense for
all of the actions that are proposed
some of them you may have noticed are
the subjects of
I'm sorry to use jargon pilots and
Pathfinders and other things which
leaves open the option of not proceeding
with those measures
I want to ask you since you've you've
raised the topic Mr Man perhaps we could
get the summary of the framework actions
on the screen it may be at page
72 and XB of this December 22 report
which of course is post covert
just have a look at some of the
propositions and the language so
to fund our bearings professor
if you you won't have a hard copy I'm
afraid of of the report in front of you
actually I do have a video Oh Well very
good well the hard copy is different
it's page 66. uh
Annex B summary of framework actions the
United Kingdom government is already
taking action by refreshing the nsra
process creating a new head of
resilience strengthening UK government
resilience structures continuing so it's
taking action already by continuing to
take International bilateral and
mightiland multilateral action and
already taking action by continuing to
deepen and strengthen its relationships
with the voluntary Community sector if
you turn over the page to page 67 in the
hard copy or 73 online
by 2025 the United Kingdom government is
committed is committing to take the
following actions
clarifying roles and responsibilities
the United Kingdom government for each
nsra risk to drive activity across the
risk life cycle
conduct an annual survey
introduce an annual same Department
develop a measurement of socioeconomic
resilience
run a pilot across the three key pillars
of reform
of leadership accountability and
integration resilience grow advisory
groups deliver new resilience Academy
deliver new training skills past week
reinvigorate the National exercising
program and over the page page 68 and
the hard copy 74 online
by 2030 the UK government will develop
proposals
to make Communications on risk more
relevant and is accessible work across
the three key pillars of Reform to
strengthen the local resilience forums
introduce standards and resilience
provide better guidance build upon
existing resilience standards
and in relation to investment have a
coordinated and prioritized approach to
investment in resilience informed by a
shared understanding of risk
consider options for funding models for
any future expanded responsibilities and
offer new guidance
so in your professional opinion Mr Man
firstly in Professor Alexander are those
propositions are those
um
commitments
sufficiently concrete
clear precise to meet the concerns that
um you both expressed already this this
afternoon no
in three centers first
if all of those were executed
the question I think needs to be
addressed is
would the UK be in a better place to
handle catastrophic emergencies
my judgment is no secondly are they
concrete to use your language
no what they don't do is first of all
set out how we'll get from here to there
in a way in which responders throughout
the community can understand
and secondly they don't have any kind of
almost any kind of metrics on okay when
we get there this is what we'll see this
is what it will look and feel like
professor
yes um there are one or two of these
that have already been done for example
the measurement of socioeconomic
resilience the British red crops has
already done that
but they are outside the system however
more substantially my feeling about this
is that it is an attempt to Tinker with
the system rather than radically
approach it with a new view
my opinion of the British civil
protection system is that it actually is
not a system it is a set of fragments
which is a way of saying that it isn't
terribly well connected despite the
spaghetti diagram uh indeed perhaps that
is diagnostic of what I'm saying
um it lacks the middle tier for example
it is very top heavy it is very top down
despite the absolute need for
um
organization at the local level it
relies heavily on the military and I
think that is a very bad thing and not
anti-military on the contrary I would
like to see the British military forces
liberated from some of the Civil
contingencies work so that they can get
on with their core business especially
as they are in the process of being
downsided with regard to their human
compliment all right the professor I'm
just going to I'm afraid I'm just going
to pause you there there are some things
that this inquiry can inquire into
um some which you can't I'm afraid
um recruitment levels and the Manning in
the Army is not one of them
no no I was not suggesting that there
should be more recruitment in the
military rather instead that the system
should be revised so that it is more
securely based on the local level the
regional level and civilian input that's
including as the House of Lords report
suggested quite strongly a far better
incorporation of the voluntary sector
into that system at a greater Reliance
including in statutory terms upon the
voluntary sector
but we'll come to many of those aspects
later
um you've referred there to to the House
of Lords committee is that the House of
Lords select committee on risk
assessment and risk planning of which to
which yes it changes yes
so just drawing This Thread together
from the debate of the last few moments
um is it because of the inadequacy of
existing
documents and strategies and also
because of your joint opinion on the
inadequacy of the government's post
covert response that you recommend at
page 23 of your report paragraph 44
professor
that a vital foundation stone to
building robust resilience preparedness
is the development by the United Kingdom
government working with default
administrations and resilience
Partnerships of a formal uk-wide
resilience strategy
yes it is are you re are you inviting in
effect
a wholesale radical rewriting or writing
of our strategic approach going forward
yes yes
coming at this issue from a different
angle you go on elsewhere in your report
to examine the the conceptual
features of of the approach applied by
the United Kingdom government and and
other governments called integrated
Emergency Management IEM
[Music]
and at page 25 of your report
could we have please
page 25 up on the screen
there is a figure figure one original
integrated Emergency Management
framework
um
we understand that
each of the blue circles signifies a
an approach or release a a broad
description of what must be done
um and there's obviously a
a strong level of
of Doctrine or conceptual analysis in
this but you've summarized
the phases in your report anticipate
Horizon scanning assess the analysis of
identified risks prevent the actions
undertaken to see to avoid a risk
um the likelihood of a risk arising
prepare the development of emergency
plans respond the action's taken to deal
with the immediate effect of an
emergency and recover and together they
form
doctrinally perhaps the framework for
emergency preparedness response and
resilience
why does
why is it necessary to to separate out
these functions in this way why is it
necessary to have what is known as an
integrated Emergency Management
framework is that not just more jargon
no I think it does two things
first
starting from the position of identified
risks
it identifies the process which knits
together the actions of a wide range of
people and organizations
into trying to avoid or reduce those
risks causing harm and loss
not every organization will have every
every one of those phases but it's
important that they can all see how when
they come together in Partnership
they can minimize harm and loss the risk
of harm and loss that's the first the
second then is
for those who are tackling let's say one
part of that emergency preparedness they
need to see the interconnections between
what they are doing what others are
doing and not work in their own silos
so
Professor you're going to say something
um simply that this is uh one of a
number of versions used in expanded risk
assessment risk management
by companies by all concerned by
governments by agencies and so on it is
necessary to tackle risks holistically
uh in a broad sort of way but to do so
it does require a structure
so in essence if I may summarize and I I
I summarize your expertise imperfectly
of course
although
in a system a proper system of emergency
preparedness
the people who need to be the people who
tell everyone else what to do need to
know what to tell them to do the people
who respond need to be told what to do
the people who draw the policies need to
draw up clear concrete and and
transparent policies that's not enough
to your second Point Mr Man
everybody playing their part in a system
of civil contingency and emergency
crisis management
needs to understand where they come into
the general scheme of things they need
to understand and you would say
Professor holistically how it all hangs
together
yes putting its simplest when the people
who have done the risk anticipation
assessment produce their National risk
assessment or whatever the next question
ought to be okay how do we avoid these
risks happening in the first place or at
least seek to minimize their impact next
or say they ought to be saying we've
taken preventative or mitigation
activity as far as we can there is this
residual set of risks and potential
emergencies which we cannot address
we're now passing it over to the
preparedness planners and the
preparedness planners will then pass it
over to the response planners and so on
it has to be integrated so the first
word is really important so this
framework is this integrated framework
is essentially in order to remind
everybody
the nature of the task in hand what
needs to be done and to ensure that
they're doing the right things in the
overall system
yes yes in Emergency Management training
half of the problem is to train people
in what they need to do the other half
of it is to train them to understand
what everyone else has to do because
this is always a collective effort
and it cannot take place on an
individual level without adequate
integration with what everyone else is
doing otherwise the results are working
at Cross purposes
and if the system or the integrated
framework is erroneous or wrong in some
regard
strategic weaknesses can follow and do
you therefore at paragraph 50 say this
form of the integrated Emergency
Management framework resulted in an
absence of focus on quality and
Effectiveness basically Ascent a an
absence of focus on ensuring that that
everybody's parts were working and that
the system was being properly tested and
found to be adequate yes and also a
focus on processes rather than people
would you elaborate on those two
weaknesses which you say strategically
resulted from this framework not being
correctly drawn up yes your first point
is absolutely right
looking at it overall
at the whole system level at the
leadership level
have we done as much as we can there is
a question have we done as much as we
can to reduce risk as far as it's
practicable and cost effective
that is the validation and Assurance
bubble
and secondly to learn lessons or where
we can do better
to reduce risk that might be about
preventative activity it might be about
having better preparedness
that involves looking at the entire
cycle overall
which is uh your point I think Mr Keith
on the people side yes as we put inside
the report
it does get very processy
products very antiseptic people use the
word
it's it's very easy to lose sight or the
fact that at the end of this this is
being done for people their safety their
welfare harm to avoid harm and loss
and one of the criticisms we make here
is or one of the suggestions for
improvement we make is get that focus on
people into all forms of activity not
only each of the bubbles but actually
into the process overall and so yeah yes
Professor
um in 2005 the London assembly produced
committee which then produced a three
volume report on the bombs of the 7th of
July and that was a day when there were
some fairly severe problems in managing
the emergency as it evolved and the very
first recommendation of that report
was that the responders and the agencies
and organizations behind them needed to
shift their focus from processes to the
beneficiaries the people they were
helping I thought at the time that that
would cause a revolution in British
Emergency Management practice because
it's in both evidently sensible and
something that clearly needed to be done
in a wide variety of Arenas I was rather
surprised to find that it simply did not
happen
um you may know Professor that my lady
was the
coroner in the
inquest in
terrible deaths of those who
died in 1977 attacks and and so what
you're saying essentially is it was
recognized and and
um I'll apologize to give me evidence
was recognized by my lady in her report
after the the inquest and by the London
assembly that like proper preparation
and proper response needs to focus more
on people rather than becoming obsessed
perhaps overly focused with the
processes themselves
exactly I'd like to emphasize that this
is in no way a criticism of any
individuals in as much as there are many
people who did precisely focus on the
people on on the outcomes and so on the
question is how much leeway to do that
if the system allow them right so if we
could have our page 27
I think it's 27 in the hard copy for you
professor
do you both recommend that in this issue
in in this identification of of
the um
the the learning and and the the
[Music]
work that has to go into identifying the
integrated system what we are all meant
to do
it is essential that to further
segments be inserted one is a Express
obligation to validate and assure that
is to say to test
and a second one to learn and improve
following recovery so that lessons are
better learned and the system is
improved along the way yes and if that
is done this melody recommends
that the integrated Emergency Management
framework be expressly altered to
include those
important features that will have a
beneficial practical
practical yes this will tell people that
as part of their day-to-day work as part
of their training those two activities
need to be recognized and done properly
all right and furthermore
um there are at least I think 62
universities in Britain that provide
expertise that is useful in this case
now some of them are directly used for
example Nottingham Trent and the fire
service Manchester Metropolitan
University and the National Health
Service emergency response however there
is a belated and rather slow realization
in government that they need to use
academic expertise more particularly
academic expertise of an applied nature
which is directly useful in the
processes of validating and learning
the next part of your report
focuses on the legislative framework and
structures this is section three of the
report and as you've already identified
the piece of legislation at the heart of
the emergency preparedness legislative
framework is the Civil contingencies act
2004.
um
in in light of the time constraints I'm
not going to take you through
even the most important parts of the ACT
could we please focus our attention on
on the act of at a broad level
the ACT provides in its first part for
duties to be imposed at local level and
I'm summarizing hugely here on two
groups of responders category one and
category two responders if perhaps we
could have up our
are spaghetti charts
I think it's imq 204014
there we are
um if we could go please to page 17
this is
uh I'm not quite sure is is that it's
just suddenly jumped is that has it
jumped to a different page
I've got the one with the 2009 down at
the bottom left yes if if we look at the
top pandemic preventative response
structures in United Kingdom in England
2009 I think that's page 17. could we
just to get our bearings have page three
and then page four if if that's not too
arduous a burden
so around about nine years later August
and the positions become rather more
complex and and of course professor your
implied the answer to your implied
question from earlier was that was that
this diagram
is not an exact reality of course as you
know very well of the reality of our
emergency parent systems and it was it
was seeking to make the forensic point
to which you referred about the
complexity of the position
and then page four should be 2019 there
we are August 2019. so right at the
bottom left we have the local resilience
forums and then we have the two types of
responders category one responders and
category two responders and is the
position that they have differing legal
duties imposed upon them
and that the ACT obliges category 1
responders to do in fact more things
than Category 2 responders obliged to do
but but it's more prescriptive and it
imposes a greater legal burden on
category 1 responders than category 2.
is that a fair summary that is correct
yeah yeah
is there an argument for changing the
the imposition of the legal duties on
category 1 and chapter 2 responders to
to make sure to bring category two
responders further into the fold to bind
them closer to category 1 responders
and and to sharpen up that part of the
system
yes believe there is for three reasons
first
we'll come back to this
if we as we propose if it is the aim to
build a system which is capable of
dealing with catastrophic emergencies
with the ability to deal with local and
Regional emergencies
then Category 2 responders
at a time when the whole country is
responding to a catastrophic emergency
have got to have
full of responsibilities than they
presently have we saw that proved in the
covid-19 pandemic can I just pause you
there could you give us please some
indication of who are the category who
the category 2 responders are and
explain why they are the sorts of
entities utilities and so on and so
forth and businesses and communication
suppliers who need to be brought into
the fold more because of the more
complex risks and the more dangerous
emergencies we're likely to face
certainly Category 2 responders are
in shorthand the people who provide the
essential services on which the country
depends to keep running so water
electricity Communications
and so on transport operators
in other words to keep the country
running here's the core point they need
to be capable of
doing effective planning and playing a
full role in the response
and that means they need
also to have played a key role in the
identification of risk and in the
preparedness planning so on the duties
which presently fall on the so-called
category 1 responders the public sector
bodies we believe that they should have
a full role in each of those activities
and therefore the duties should fall on
them first point second point
the future risk picture especially with
climate change
the leading effects of climate change
means actually that some of the most
significant emergencies may start with
the provision of essential Services
electricity failure telecommunications
outage
flooding
and so on that also in our view
increases the responsibility on them to
undertake those activities thirdly
in the review independent review which I
conducted it was very clear that there
was a there was a developing art and
them this did not feel like equal
partnership it was a mixed picture but
it did not feel like an equal
partnership and equal partnership is
exactly what is needed for dealing with
a catastrophic emergency
Professor do you want to add to those
three points
between the world of cascading disasters
and the Cascade often occurs through the
failure of critical infrastructure which
has between 8 and 11 categories it is
things like water and sewerage
electricity gas supply
Transportation Healthcare emergency
response but if we lose electricity I
can fairly easily think of about 38
different consequences that would stop
life being lived as normal if we merely
consider the effect of having no
electricity on banking it could freeze
up just about everything for the simple
reason that the circulation the supply
and the use of money is entirely
nowadays dependent on electricity one
way or the other so in fact there are
plenty of opportunities for critical
infrastructure failure to be absolutely
Central to the emergency and that is a
very good reason for ensuring that it's
operators have greater power was in
Greater legal requirements and and
is the proposition underpinning what you
both just said that
the imposition of legal duties is
necessary to ensure
that
whoever the responders are they step up
to the mark that that do the planning
that is expected of them they draw up
the plans they validate them they have
them tested they engage with the public
they engage with other responders and so
on and so forth that they do the job in
hand yes it is and that how well they do
the job is the subject of validation and
Assurance religion to what extent is
central government
or Regional government
or the default Administration subject to
any comparable legal duties just before
you move to that Keith emergency
question you said there are examples
during the covid pandemic in the UK as
to why you think this Duty should be put
on category responders could you give an
example of this uh yes uh
it's not so much failure in that case we
might come to other examples of that
critical infrastructure failure
but the key Point especially in the
first wave of the pandemic the key
issues were how to keep essential
Services being provided
to citizens in the economy so that is
continue to keep electricity food water
transportation running
I understand that but I thought what
you're saying was you're about to give
examples as to why there should be this
Duty in other words that things had gone
wrong because there wasn't this Duty you
weren't saying that no I wasn't saying
that my lady I'd use other examples for
that
but it is at a convenient moment
well I I would add that the law may be
considered as a means of punishment but
it is also a great enabler and one thing
that it can do is to bring the providers
of essential services and others more
firmly into the system
I think I'd ask you to what extent
are comparable legal duties imposed on
central government
Regional government and the devault
Administrations
central government there are two
government departments which are
designated Department of Health and
Department transport who are designated
in the jargoners category 1 responders
the rest of central government the UK
government central government
departments are not and that I believe
is the case in the default
demonstrations
there are other aspects in which the ACT
distinguishes between the United Kingdom
government and the devil administrations
but we need to trouble ourselves about
that now what about Regional government
so combined authorities May
or Regional government is not covered
combined authorities are not covered in
any way in any in the act or any of its
supporting documentation
in your report do you recommend the
consideration be given
to the imposition imposition of the
legal duties or a variant thereof in the
Civil contingencies act 2004 to central
government in in a in general terms and
to Regional government beyond the
specific identification of the two
departments to which you may reference
yes I draw a distinction uh in a for
exactly the same reasons the ability to
manage a catastrophic emergency to take
a leadership role in a catastrophic
emergency that sense of partnership we
believe that duties should apply to
central government uniformly not just
those two departments
I'd make instincts on combined
authorities
they need absolutely to be part of their
system but I think more thought needs to
be given as especially in the light of
this government's proposals for
Devolution and the greater more combined
authorities as to what those duties if
there were any would look like and how
they should best be fitted inside the
system
has the argument for the imposition of
legal duties in the general Sense on
central government strengthened as a
result of the government's response to
the covert pandemic uh unquestionably
yes but what that has brought out for me
is two things first
that leadership role
that partnership role in leading an
emergency and secondly as we put in
the independent review report some
deficiencies which we heard about in
their preparedness
to a degree because they did not have
legal duties and it was not therefore
one of the major things on the radar
screens of the senior leaders of those
departments all right
the two other aspects structural aspects
to this child or or this this um
representation of pandemic and
preparedness and response structures
that I want to ask you about
um
in fact three firstly the top left we
can see pandemic preparedness and
response structures
when dealing with
the identification of the bodies and the
entities that are all that are concerned
generally in the United Kingdom's
response to emergencies is it important
to distinguish between preparedness and
response so there are different duties
in different bodies depending on whether
you're dealing with preparedness or
response
so for example the distinction between
local resilience forums and strategic
coordinating groups
I'm hesitating on your word distinction
Mr Case the two need to be
umbilically linked
whatever's done in preparedness is
probably being done and the plans that
are being developed are probably going
to be used by the same people when you
become when it goes into the response
there is a very narrow question which is
whether it makes any sense any longer to
have a distinction between local
resilience forms on the one hand as it
were peacetime
bodies and strategic coordination groups
on the other hand
the organizations the the forums that
manage a major emergency I think there
are arguments either way
uh I do think it needs to be explored I
would say that there are
differences in membership there are
differences in role there are
differences in legal responsibility
local resilience forms have legal duties
but most importantly there are
differences of culture as between a
meeting of a local resilience form on
the one hand
and a strategic coordination Group which
is there to tackle an emergency those
need to be thought through carefully but
I think it is a very good question but
professor before I ask you to come into
this
just can I map you just ask a follow-up
question and then I'll ask you to
comment generally
um in your own report Mr Mann and
Professor Alexander you separate out
by reference to preparedness and then
response all the many structures so I
think well section four deals with
preparedness and your section 5 dealt
with
response and so many of the same bodies
to which you referred in one area were
replicated in the other and then of
course you've
you've identified that many of the
bodies have both response and
preparedness functions
is there an argument for
radical reform in terms of
trying not to draw out that distinction
between preparedness and response in
terms of identifying the right bodies
and the right duties to impose on them
is this an unnecessary complication now
I do not want to suggest that
there should be a sweeping
as it were a sweep of the hand and all
of these bodies be
response and and preparedness be merged
into everybody every organization every
Forum
all the way through this chart
I think it needs very careful thought
not least on the purpose
of the organization or the Forum
before making that decision professor
no well the Americans did try to if not
merge at least bring very firmly
together 125 Federal organizations after
9 11 in the creation of the Department
of Homeland Security and I'm not sure
that that was actually a terribly well
thought out move
um
I think there needs to be more of a
sense of constancy in the way that
emergencies are managed rather than
having thorough that meet at intervals
and groups that are coordinated to
manage emergencies when they occur I
think there really should be something
that is there all the time constantly
upgrading the planning and so on but I'd
like to mention one other thing about
your diagram and about the British
strategy and that is that International
Security risk assessment and so on there
is the concept of the agency that owns
the risk usually a government Department
I rather don't like at least the
terminology
perhaps I'm crippling over semantics but
I don't think risks are really owned by
individual departments they're owned by
all of us although it is important to
have perhaps a lead agency with regard
to specific scenarios or specific risks
it is also important that there is a
collaborative and shared effort
Professor if we meet if you say so I
think by with your appeal to plain
English you are with this tribunal
kicking it an open door but perhaps we
we can't know I think in the course of
this inquiry or at least an inquiry
lasting less than three years deal with
all aspects of the language in this
system which are
um I'm now going to just delve into it
unfortunate but
the point is well made but we'll come
back to risk Assessments in a moment
so so that's one area the second area I
wanted to ask you both about was if you
look in the the left-hand side of the
the diagram you will see
the resilience emergencies division
which is the liaison
between
local resilience forums and local
authorities and also tactical
coordination groups and strategic
coordination groups and the body above
it the government Department which was
the minister of Ministry of housing
communities and local government but is
now the department of leveling up
housing and communities
if if we were but it'll take too long to
go back to the diagram 10 or so years
before there used to be a government
body known as the government offices for
the regions
and they provided a secretary at
something called Regional resilience
forums and they were the liaison with
all the local bodies
or at least the majority of them
was that change whereby
the link if you like between central
government and and local Authority was
put into the department of leveling up
housing communities through its
resilience emergencies division an
improvement or was that a retrograde
step no right my belief is it was a
retrograde step I'll start on the
technical aspects Professor Alexander
will probably talk about experience in
other countries I think it's a
retrograde step for three reasons first
um
on risk assessment and planning
there are risks which are not all risk
stay nicely confined within the
boundaries of a local resident form area
there are risks across boundaries there
needs to be risk assessment done on a
regional level there needs to be
planning done on a regional level as
well as training and exercising and so
on and experience has shown that that
has degraded
in the course of the last 10 years first
point second Point those Regional
resilience teams
were Boots eyes ears on the ground they
knew what was going on they could report
back they could have a quiet word in the
air they were a first line Assurance
capability
that people in the organizations were
undertaking tasks well
that again
as we found in the independent review
was gone
thirdly when it comes to an emergency
what we have at the moment is 38
entities
local regions foreign strategic command
groups going into one government
Department I just don't think that can
be done can I before I ask Professor
Alexander to come in on this
um can I ask you please Mr Man you were
of course director of the Civil
contingency secretary from 2004 to 2009.
this changed fundamental change took
place after your watch that they did in
2011. yes well
were there indications of this change
was you are still in office in that post
or was this all entirely after your time
uh all entirely after my time it was the
incoming Administration uh that uh made
a number of changes to local and
Regional levels the governance of
England and this was one of them always
Professor do you want to add anything to
the point about the red the resilience
yeah yes please I was a member of the
east of England Brazilians Forum which
coordinated the work in six counties it
had great potential that it had no
resources and no Authority which was
extremely frustrating
therefore it wasn't able to achieve very
much although it did achieve something
and I was sorry to see it go
I'm familiar with regional work in a
variety of different countries for
example in Sweden Portugal Spain and so
on and particularly in Italy and during
covid it was most notable that the
regions were the Lynch pin absolutely
television viewers on the news three
times a week would see a film whip of
the Prime Minister in front of 20
screens on each of the screens there
were the presidents of each of the 20
regions Ovid was very different in each
region the purpose of central government
was to support variously unfairly the
work against cobit of the regions and in
Italy the regions run the Health Service
so that was really important in both
civil protection and health maintenance
Burns and I think that that worked out
extremely well it also meant that
attention it could be given at the right
level to the sorts of work and support
required locally
which simply could not be managed
nationally
so I do believe that one of the things
that
written most needs is a proper Regional
tier I don't think that the Metropolitan
authorities are sufficient for that for
example it might be helpful to have a
regional tier that encompasses both
Liverpool and Manchester
and things like that all right
the the next and and the final General
point of relations are structures
concerned
something that you've already referred
to in fact repeatedly the the lead
government department now
um
again dealing with the United Kingdom
structure not because the D.A the
default Administration structure is any
less important but it's it's convenient
to be able to identify in the UK
structure of this entity
an absolutely core feature of the
emergency preparedness systems in the
United Kingdom is that there is always
identified a lead government Department
which must maintain a state of Readiness
and lead the charge in terms of the
response to emergencies
for which it is the nominated central
government lead so if there is a
government Department which is which
takes the lead in relation to uh an
animal disease it's going to be the
department for Health and Social care
which is why
in this chart which deals primarily with
covert of course and and preparedness
for pandemics
the lead government department is the
department for Health and Social care
in your report
you
identify that
in relation to National crises and
complex emergencies and particularly
cascading emergencies
a number of departments will have to be
involved
so for example in relation to covid you
would have had the Department of
Education in relation to schools you've
got HMT in relation to financial support
you've got the home office in relation
to borders and enforcement and so on and
so forth
what flaws have you identified in
relation to the local government at the
lead government Department model
the most obvious systemic issue is
whether for a catastrophic emergency
a lead government Department
can oversee
preparedness for and the response
on all of the issues including a wide
range of issues which are outside its
direct scope and responsibility
yes um
usually the ministry of the Interior or
in other words the home office which is
the the minister and the ministry that
runs civil protection and it was the
Italians in 1999 who decreased to Europe
a non-binding European Union directive
but civil protection should really be a
dependency of the cabinet as a whole
because of the need to give full weight
to other Ministries Health Public Works
whatever the economy whatever the
Ministries might be and that was adopted
by a number of countries and more or
less by Britain as well
um and that was absolutely necessary to
avoid the marginalization of particular
government Ministries and departments
and when covert of course struck a very
large number of government departments
were engaged
was the flaw that when more than one
lead government Department had to
respond and take responsibility for
important parts of the country's
response
the lines of accountability
and transparency in leadership blurred
because nobody could say there was one
single lead government that was in
charge
I think there are two
parts of the answer to that question
there's a preparedness part to it
which is who should lead
on areas which are outside the
responsibility of the so-called lead
government Department
and make sure that those are
planned for properly and what is needed
is in place is that the lead government
department or is that somebody outside
the cabinet office
that's the first question second
question then is in the response phase
is it the lead gum department or is the
cabinet office absolutely a shoulder
at the lectern for every press
conference given the Prime Minister and
so on my personal view is for the most
catastrophic and complex emergencies
there should be that shared
responsibility not a single
responsibility that shared
responsibility lead government
Department with the cabinet office using
its convening power
in the preparedness phase and in the
response phase to get all other entities
behind the response
professor before I ask you for your
response could I just please ask you
this Mr Man
you yourself have just divided or drawn
an Extinction between preparedness and
response in the context of a lead gun
department and identifying which one is
the maybe the lead government Department
it is that because
in in our current system there may in
the currency of a single emergency even
have to be a change of leave government
department so you might have
flooding
where deathra might be the lead
government Department because it
responds to matters concerning the
environment and flooding and so on but
then when the the emergency moves to the
response stage another government
Department a different League of
Department maybe the more appropriate
Department
no I would never change horses in
Midstream
um the people who did the planning the
people who did the thinking all to the
people who were involved in the response
I think my my point is that there's a
range of smaller scale emergencies anal
disease outbreaks flooding and so on
where people will naturally look to the
legal department the obvious Department
that is right because the and the
activities that need to be done I think
I think we may be across mountains I may
not have put the question clearly enough
you can put it after you've had the
break was to give you a chance well that
gives you a chance to reformulating
exactly
right um 20 past please
thank you
guys
foreign
Mr Man I think that we may have been
across purposes what I was asking you
was whether or not
and I confess I haven't really reformed
it to the question uh
are there ever occasions in which in the
course of an emergency there may be a
change in the nominated lead government
department so for example
drawing on the witness statement of Mr
Hargreaves your successor as the
Director of the Civil contingency
Secretariat
a flood
may require defra to be nominated as the
lead gum department for the purposes of
the initial
response but for the purposes of
recovery D like the department of
leveling up housing and communities May
then become the league young Department
yes I'm certainly found misunderstood
you Mr Keith yes there are two
circumstances first because the
immediate emergency has cascaded into
another emergency we have that at
bunsfield we had a foreign explosion and
then we had an acute shortage of
kerosene to Heathrow Airport
the leadership changed in that
circumstance secondly then for the
recovery phase absolutely the Instinct
the the usual preference would be to
pass it to dluck the second question
that I wanted to ask just my way of
clarification um do you happen to recall
when epri emergency preparedness
response from resilience became devolved
in so far as Wales was concerned
the transfer functions order the
transfer of financial order 2018 2018. I
knew you'd get that so just to deal then
with the lead government department and
to conclude that issue
the lead government Department
or at least a government department will
have a general responsibility for a for
a one or more critical sectors so
they're obviously government departments
that deal with
particular areas of the infrastructure
particular areas of
critical importance
at the same time there are different gun
departments that own to use that
terrible word different risks
so in the course of a response to an
emergency
in reality
more than one
government department is likely to be
for the
inscribed in the course of covert a
multitude of government departments were
engaged
what government body
is responsible in advance of an
emergency for ensuring that each
government Department's plans and
procedures and policies are up-to-date
correctly drawn up
properly written
and and do the right job
and ensuring that each of those
government departments has to use
the seemingly the right the the correct
literature assured itself tested itself
and also responsible for ensuring
proper collaboration between government
departments and making sure they all
work smoothly together in the event of a
crisis
none
this is a quick and simple answer is
there there are pieces
of that jigsaw
where they can be that validation down
Assurance is there anyone who is
checking that that job that that work is
cross-checking that work is being done
properly
checking the whole system will work
together there is no such department
does not the cabinet office
liaise at least with government
departments to ensure that they are
doing what they're meant to do in
advance of a crisis brokering
Arrangements cooperate ensuring proper
cooperation and in the event of a crisis
both assisting government departments to
respond collectively as well as putting
into place the physical Arrangements
like Cobra and so on and so so forth
to make it happen
yes that is not the same as a rigorous
cross-check against standards have you
got in place the capabilities you need
are they well-trained exercise and so on
either at the level of the individual
organization or at the level of the
whole I'm I'm in an area this important
it needs that forensic checking and that
is not done but I I sense that you are
focusing with your answer upon the
particular issue of Standards which
we'll come to in a moment which is is
the general word given to the system by
which
anybody whether it be a local resilience
Forum or a regional resilience Forum or
a strategic coordinating group or red of
d-lac or or the lead government
Department
meets a certain standard that it's
tested it's validated to use your word
it's it's it's
checked
there is no one body that is responsible
for checking the various moving Parts I
think Professor Alexander's physically
had his hand up yeah so thank you
um I was just thinking that it's
possible that one is looking at this
from the wrong perspective in other
words back to front because what really
matters is solving problems as they
arrive I would therefore expect
the system to be able to identify the
problems and allocate them to those who
can solve them in other words the
various departments
uh with a degree of flexibility and
general ability to respond rapidly
rather than
purely being aware beforehand of what is
likely to happen and who is likely to
need to be responsible that certainly is
what is done in scenarios but there is
also a process not merely a prior
planning but of adapting plans to
dynamically evolving circumstances I
think this was very very evident in
covid because initially we didn't know
what was going on because it was an
emerging disease which the
characteristics were
partly or largely unknown and later we
learn more about it and it becomes more
clear what is needed to be done and
problems also arise out of that out of
the disruption that it causes that need
to be allocated to depose so perhaps we
should look at it from the point of view
of the needs as much as from the point
of view of the needs of the department
would disagree with with that Professor
I was asking Mr Man there about
what the current
which entities the current structure
provides for to do the testing the
validating and keeping the the
government organizations in line
could I could I ask you one more time
therefore in in the in this way
you have described for us
how there is a system by which
local resilience forums are
broadly but indirectly connected through
to a particular division the resilience
and emergency division in the department
of leveling up and housing communities
you've described a system whereby in
terms of preparing and analyzing and
identifying risks and in terms of being
responsible for response in critical
sectors a government Department
may have a great deal to do and in the
context of a complex or cascading
emergency a significant number of
government departments may all be
reacting preparing and then reacting
it appears that this is a very complex
system with the loss of moving parts
and that there is therefore a need for a
single body whether it be external to
government or within government
to manage and control these various
moving parts
would you agree I would agree
and I believe there is no such entity
who is either checking the individual
parts or the whole total system
Professor would you agree
yes I would agree I would agree exactly
as Mr man has said right thank you now
can we look please because a great deal
of your report properly deals with the
Vault administrations at the position in
Scotland Wells Northern Ireland and have
please on the screen the organogram
whilst that's coming up on screen
um if there ought to be one entity uh
the framework that I criticized earlier
for its lack of using English
um
that talked about appointing a national
resilience officer would that meet the
bill or it's not not going far enough
no I it's a separate point my lady I do
believe there needs to be a single
person the chief resilience officers
we've labeled him in charge of making
sure that the system is good
and that Chief resilience officer should
have available to him or her some form
of team that can make sure that that
validation Assurance is done so the one
officer is not enough they've got to
have the backup yeah they need to get
out onto the ground and check that what
is being done in individual entities is
right thank you and Milady will come
back to the question of whether or not
there should be an agency a body
internal or external and how it should
be headed but for present purposes Mr
Man do you understand that the
had new head of resilience in relation
to which an Annex B of the December 22
UK government resilience framework the
United government says is already taking
action by creating a new head of
resilience
has a new head of resilience been
appointed
if a new head residence has been
appointed I do I've not seen that
announcement I don't know who it is has
the government identified a particular
entity or body within which a new head
resilience might even operate not as far
as I'm aware is the government's current
plan that a new header resilience would
even is in fact somebody who would
simply be a new post
within an existing government Department
the role of the head of resilience the
location of the head of resilience is
left quite vague in the
resilience framework so I'm afraid I
can't answer the question because
um the material there is vague and I
haven't seen no subsequent announcements
thank you
um
so there is the organogram could we
please have
slowly
um in relation to Scotland please page
eight I hope this will work page eight
then page seven then Page Six
so this is 2010 page eight
is this position that
towards the bottom of the page and we
can see
uh local resilience Partnerships and
above them strategic coordination groups
that um over time I think
the Strategic coordinating groups I
think it should be strategic
coordinating groups not coordination
groups became Regional resilience
Partnerships
that's correct if we go forward please
to page
seven which is 2017. we can see in the
bottom left Regional resilience
Partnerships and then forward to page
six
2019 the position on the Advent of covid
there we are so still their original
resilience Partnerships and
does everything that you have already
said in relation to
the integrated Emergency Management
framework in relation to the legal
obligations under the Civil contentious
Act 2004.
what you have said in relation to the
proper approach to identification of
group risks as opposed to specific risk
or specific risks as opposed to group
risks apply equally
to the pandemic preparedness and
response structures in Scotland
yes is the integrated emerging Emergency
Management framework the same in all
administrations in the UK yes with one
small exception which is in Scotland
they put the anticipation of risk and
the assessment of risk together but
otherwise it is the same
one major difference of course is that
in the Scottish system there is no
Department of leveling up housing in
communities because resilience is a
devolved matter and it is all therefore
run by the Scottish government and not
obviously by a Westminster government
Department
and there is no resilience emergency
division
if you look at the left-hand side of the
page
the link between the local resilience
Partnerships and Below them the category
one two responders comes up to the
Scottish government and ministers
through the Scottish resilience
partnership and the Scottish government
liaison officers
is there anything that you want to say
about that system in the context of
Scotland I I think is of much preferable
system for the reasons I described
earlier
the secret thank you Professor it is
also evident in Scotland that there is
one unitary government body identified
here the Scottish government
so you don't have here
the identification of a particular
government Department as you had on the
UK chart namely Department of Health and
Social care
is the Scottish structure better insofar
as you don't have the danger
that you've identified a few moments ago
of more than one government Department
attempting to to lead the charge in
response to a multiple or complex or
cascading emergency
I'm not sure I see the distinction Mr
Keith there is in the middle the blue
box the Health and Social care
directorate
which to me the analog of the Department
of Health and Social care
is the is the system is the is the
departmental system in Scotland as
complex and therefore as as
um diffuse or and as liable perhaps to
hmm
a lack of control
as the United Kingdom model the United
Kingdom model has a wide range if you
think about the various component parts
of the response to a catastrophic
emergency
the United Kingdom Government model has
four or five leaders or particular
components cabinet office the lead
Department Department leveling up and
actually the department of cultural
medium sport who've got sponsorship for
the voluntary secretary that is very
very diffuse and Federated leadership it
is not Clarity of leadership and is
especially it's not Clarity of
leadership in an emergency
and that is not something of which you
would say the the um from which the
Scottish
system suffers
uh that would be my view yes right but
if you look at the top of the page
plainly in relation to an emergency that
affects the whole United Kingdom
including all its constituent Parts its
countries
there is still that link there as
they're not up through
Sage by which we'll hear a great delmora
module to COBRA the cabin office
briefing room which are the physical
emanation or at least cobras the
physical imagination of the cabinet
office in London
it ought to be the physical emanation or
bringing everybody together from
whatever Administration in the
management of the emergency yes so it's
not just the UK government
but but this is the link from Edinburgh
to London
because the cabinet office is in London
and Cobra is in London and in a National
Emergency that is where the link exists
uh yes this is the dominant link there
will be others on science and on between
chief medical officers and so on but
this is the dominant link
and then finally in relation to the
Scottish model if you look at the top
right hand corner of the page National
Security risk assessment to National
risk register is the system for the
identification of risk
the apportionment of risk to particular
sectors the grouping of risks the
analysis of planning assumptions as a
result of those risks and then the
sending out to everybody of what those
risks are and how they should respond
the same in Scotland as in Westminster
do they use the same nsra it starts from
the same nsra which covers all
Administrations
uh it is then for each Administration to
choose to take it down the nsra down
into its own risk assessment and the
administration's Wales has Scotland do
and is that why underneath the nsra you
can see a line to Scottish risk
assessment exactly and then that line is
the line from there down to the Scottish
government resilience room is that the
Scottish equivalent for
assessing the impact of risks in
Scotland that is the equivalent of Cobra
the cabinet office briefing room in
London yes this chart does not cover all
of the material they had in the UK
government chart there will be peace
time as it were non-crisis activity
taking being taken forward on the basis
of the risk assessment which is not just
about the resilience room all right
could we have please Paige
10 of the organogram up please in
relation to Wales
as you said a few moments ago the uh
resilience and preparedness became a
devolved issue that is to say it is a
matter dealt with exclusively by the
Welsh government and its first minister
in 2018 under the transfer of functions
order
you can see in the bottom left hand
corner of the page
the whale strategic coordinating groups
that's the response function
to the top right of that body
the local resilience forums of which
there are four in Wales by comparison to
a much larger number in England
and above that going up the left hand
side of the page
the wells resilience partnership team
The Joint Emergency Services Group the
emergency coordination Center which all
feeds in the Welsh government
is there a regional structure in Wales
in the same way that there is a regional
structure in England no
and
does
what you have said in relation to
integrated Emergency Management in
relation to the risk assessment process
in relation to
the
the need for Central accountable and
transparent body to lead the charge
apply equally to the well structure
yes it does
in relation to Northern Ireland
Paige
14 please
civil contingencies are largely devolved
in in Northern Ireland
it's not it's not the same as wells in
Scotland on account of the existence of
the executive office
but we can see at the top the cabin
office again and the National Security
Secretariat Cobra The Briefing room top
right the the risk assessment process
which feeds in through the Northern
Ireland risk assessment process into the
office of the Northern Ireland executive
which is the office of the first
Minister and Deputy first minister
and something that will come to and
address in more detail tomorrow the
Civil contingencies group in the Civil
contingencies group for ministers and
officials and then at the bottom of the
page
there are three emergency
preparedness groups
I say at the bottom of the page
the pink box in the middle Mr Case
I've completely lost it bottom of the
pink box on the left hand side
there we are thank you very much
emergency preparedness groups of which
there are three
and they feed up to the Regional
Community resilience groups the Regional
Recovery forum and up through the
northern London emergency preparedness
group into the the ministerial and civil
service
functions in a large yellow box so again
broadly similar that there are
differences are there not in terms of
the
the legal duties under the Civil
contingencies act but they need and
trouble us there are differences in
some non-devolved functions but do the
broad points that you've made apply
equally to Northern Ireland
yes can you bring a range of bodies
together in Partnership under clear
leadership to try to avoid harm and loss
the architecture will vary from a
demonstration to Administration but the
core principles are the same
all right
in page in your report at page 56
you
you turn two and this is your division
between preparedness and response you
you turn to
structures in the response phase
uh this is the um
for your report 2033
page 56.
thank you
um
because that's something about what we
were dealing with uh before uh for the
record
um
so I'm very much in favor of evolution
in civil protection I am concerned about
the gray areas which are essentially two
uh one is the extent of United Kingdom
that means Westminster Authority uh
particularly in Wales and Scotland and
the other is cross-border events that's
to say emergencies which involve both
sides of the border and therefore both
systems I did gather from the witness
statements that there were
um some concerns among representatives
of Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
about the extent of their powers during
a major emergency uh something that the
soul contingencies Act is fairly clear
on but not completely clear and which
subsequent legislation and organization
have apparently failed to clear up
completely the other is how well all of
this would perform when we have to have
the English and for example the Welsh
systems functioning side by side in
Harmony and I know that for example in
the diagram for Northern Ireland there
is apparently no reference to southern
Ireland and the possibility of
cross-border events there is also very
significant and I would expect to see at
least an office of liaison with Dublin
um yes
um Professor thank you for that of
course
um
the Republic of Ireland is not in that
chart because the chart represents
schematically the position in the United
Kingdom but my lady will be addressing
the issue of
cross-border communication given that
Island the island of Ireland is a single
epidemiological entity in the course of
module 2 C Villages happily for the
future
um thank you the
page 56 at paragraph 163 you refer to
non-statutary guidance did the
civil contingencies act provide for
all these the local bodies the the um
the responders and so on and so forth to
be the The Grateful recipient of a large
amount of statutory and non-statutary
guidance
yes it did whether grateful or not in
the matter but I guess it will indeed
so
um just with a broad eye to the position
um from the Viewpoint of a local
resilience forum
or a category one or two responder is
the following
a broadly correct identification of the
sorts of documents which they might have
to have regard to under this
system
they will have to know and understand
the government's responding to emergency
conops document the revision to
emergency preparedness cabinet is
document all of 591 pages
the emergency response and Recovery
document from the cabinet office
how to engage with and be guided by the
resilience capabilities program they'd
have to engage with engagement and
guidance material from the dhsc on the
pandemic influence of preparedness
program
material from the pandemic flu Readiness
board multiple successive editions of
the national resilience standards the
local risk management guidance
humanitarian aspects in emergency
management
Department of Health pandemic
preparedness strategy Department of
Health pandemic preparedness and
response the 2014 influenza strategic
framework
they'd have to compile Community risk
registers and they would obviously have
to be familiar with each one of perhaps
22 or more risks identified by
Westminster as being risks to which they
must have concern have regard
is that a fair summary of the sort of
level
of
guidance paperwork and policy material
yes it is I've just put an overlay on it
some of that is statutory
and some of that is non-stategory and
some is lower level guidance on best
practice so there are
a number of filters which they should
use in
um approaching those documents
you say it paragraph 354 on page 123
much further into your report that much
of the guidance has in fact not been
updated and moreover that there is no
Central directory can we have page 123
paragraph 354 please
if you go back one page please to one
two two you'll start to see some of the
material
to which I've I've made reference and
you say it a paragraph 354 it is Gravely
disappointing that so much of the key
generic resilience and preparedness
Doctrine and guidance was not updated
for the United Kingdom government during
the relevant period
and is it the position in fact that
two of the most essential documents
let's say the guidance in the cabin
office called responding to emergencies
concepts of operations
um
which you will know of Mr Man
prior to to your role as an expert
because it was first published in March
2010 shortly after you left the cabin
office
it was last updated in which year
if you recall
2013 I believe and the emergency
preparedness Doctrine which is the
general guidance from the cabin office
for local authorities and local
resilience forums and so on the 591 page
document to which I've made reference
was that updated last in March 2012.
yes in the series of individual chapter
updates yes yes section six I think was
updated
is there a very strong argument for
having this profusion of paperwork
brought together in single guidance or
at least in a single location
I think there need to be two things
first of all
a nice simple map as to where it all is
people should not have to fight to
discover it especially to fulfill their
jobs effectively secondly in this day
and age it ought to be a 500 page
document there are different ways of
presenting and packaging these things so
that people who need specific aspects of
a 500 page document can pull down what
they need on specific aspects
Professor do you want to add anything to
that if you if you say yes if you agree
then the transcript will pick up your
nod but there is simply one other aspect
that has to be dealt with and that is
secrecy
uh
information that is classified is
something of a problem
studies or recommendations have
suggested that a good portion of any of
it could be Declassified and indeed some
of it that is classified as not for
public consumption is nevertheless in
the public domain in other form
uh so that I think needs to be part of
the view and the changes
thank you
can we then move to the issue to which
you referred earlier Mr Mann and I which
I promised you we would come back to you
which is that of national resilience
standards
what are National resilience standards
they are
a series of standards in a particular
topic area like risk assessment for
example that set out three levels of
practice what is necessary to be
compliant with the Civil contingencies
act then two further levels to in the
jargon good and leading practice
and
is there a single document called
National resilience standards that if
you are the chair for example a senior
member of the police in your locality
and your chair in local resilience Forum
you can go to and say those are our
national resilience standards they
test validate or assure whichever word
you want to use
our functions
if I put myself in the shoes as indeed I
have done in separate work my shoe and
myself and shoes of the chairs of local
resilience forums there are 15 documents
which can go into a lease Leaf binder
they will tell me
eventually the answers to one question
am I compliant with the duties in the
act
they will not of themselves provide an
answer to yes I am compliant
but actually is this local resilience
Forum ready to respond to all of the
risks on this risk register first point
second Point as well as the national
resilience standards there are two other
excellent and rather elderly documents
which have not been I won't trouble you
with the details but they've not been
withdrawn so actually the standard set
is confusing from the point of view of
let's say the chair of a local
resilience Forum what are those 200
documents can I trouble you for that uh
yes of course the so-called expectation
set and the uh published a little before
the national museum standards and then
the roles and responsibilities of lrs
the expectation set was published in
December 2010 the role of nrfs in March
11 have either been withdrawn or updated
uh diversify knowledge no they haven't
and therefore if local resilience forums
are trying to see if they're either
compliant or ready they've got a
confusing picture to look at by contrast
in Scotland is there a very useful
document called preparing Scotland which
sets out in one place
the principles and standards which which
must be applied by the local bodies in
Scotland it sets only one place with a
very good map where all of the relevant
guidance is so that people do not have
to fight to access it
it does make clear that
low Regional bodies and local bodies
should conduct their own assessments of
their compliance and redness what it
does not have to the best of my
knowledge is a set of Standards against
which those assessments should be made
all right
when the draft civil contingencies bill
came before parliament in 2003
the the bill that became the Civil
confused Act 2004. did the Parliamentary
joint committee recommend a dedicated
inspectorate to ensure
adherence to standards which could be
identified yes
it's obvious self-evident that that no
inspectorate was
formed but did the Civil contingencies
act actually provide for a system of
monitoring and enforcement at least by
web allowing ministers to call for
explanation
yes it did uh there are two sections
that deal with with that have they ever
been utilized as far as I know they've
never been utilized and they do involve
taking cases to the high court which is
quite a dramatic intervention
did the audit commission until March
2015 exercise some limited external
audit activity and Assurance activity
for public sectors in the emergency
services and wider NHS and I believe the
audit commission did until it was
abolished and so do some other bodies in
this field in the new light services
there was something called the national
resilience capabilities survey between
2007 and 2014 every two years
did that end
yes in 2017. do you know why it was
discontinued
no I I read that Minister's thought that
the money could be spent better
elsewhere I do not know what lies
underneath that judgment was that a
survey in fact directed to local bodies
on a self-assessment basis so they were
asked to check their own homework that's
correct and in fact in 2014 was the
takeout rate of self-assured testing 29
percent
yes
so do you
at page 91 of your report
recommend
a
systematic new rigorous evidence-based
process for checking stand
testing the policies and procedures and
the plans drawn up by various bodies are
adequate and proper
yes I do in a field of such significance
where human huge human life is at stake
then that checking the capabilities are
in place and that they are good enough I
believe to be fundamental
and if you then go to page 92 if I'm
sorry for that very quickly uh
absolutely agreed but I would add to
that that the procedures and so on are
compatible given that we are dealing
with what is or should be a system that
involves evolved administrations local
administrations local resilience for and
so on and so forth
then when procedures are applied in
order to obtain results they need to be
compatible unless we're dealing with a
very smallest class of emergency
thank you page 92 the following page
do you say that if the government is to
comply with its duty to protect its
citizens is vital they have high quality
assessments of the preparedness of the
whole system
and drawing on good practice in a range
of countries you recommend
substantially bolstering those National
resilience standards of which you've
spoken embedding them in an inspection
regime
developing newer engines under which the
category 2 responders the responders to
whom you referred earlier as being the
ones who currently have
exist under a lesser legal Duty
should be assessed against the revised
national standards the cabin office
should develop a standard approach in
methodology for reviewing
and over the page
you suggest a compliance and
preparedness review team in the cabinet
office
and
if we remind ourselves earlier you said
that government departments should
themselves be subject to an enhanced
legal Duty in the same way that local
authorities and their bodies are
and you say on page 94 all compliance
and preparedness reviews and their
resulting action plan should be brought
together
by the cabin office the resilience
division this college government the
resilience team in the Welsh government
civil contingencies policy Branch the
executive office in Northern Ireland to
provide an overarching annual report on
the state of resilience of preparedness
yes in an area of such importance where
the sum of the risks are catastrophic
enough hideous consequences
it seems to be a reasonable question
that senior leaders ought to ask how
ready are we to respond to those risks
and indeed in the other countries in
which I have worked
including in preparing risk assessment
it is normally the first question any
senior Minister asks thank you the risk
assessment what do we do with it how
ready are we as a country
because you referred earlier to the
highly distributed leadership or diffuse
leadership
you recall that we were debating And
discussing the the the multitude of
government departments and different
parts of different departments and the
cabin offices role do you go further
page 112
foreign
for the purposes of accountability
as well as management and control of the
various moving Parts in this system
there should be
a single body
at UK level in order
to provide a proper accountable
transparent strategy
to this hugely important area
and it should be
you suggest a self-standing body rather
than part of a UK government Department
in order that in part
it can bring control and management and
supervision to the
itself
yes I do
would such a body require clear and
visible leadership
hey yes that goes to the question I was
when I'm a lady I believe
that there needs to be a single point of
focus
both in terms of a single body not the
diffuse Arrangements that existed at
present
and the single individual official level
and most likely a ministerial level
who has that visible responsibility and
accountability for the state of
preparedness and resilience more broadly
inside the United Kingdom
it's not preparing yes Professor please
it may be necessary if such a body and a
personage is created to make the leader
responsible directly to the cabinet and
the Prime Minister which is another
European recommendation that various
countries have taken up
this is after all a matter of national
emergencies
the inquiry is aware Miss man and
Professor Alexander that there are
currently a number of
ministerial posts concerned with civil
contingencies as
an implementation
there is the men the chancellor of the
duchy of Lancaster
there are
ministerial positions which have
responsibility for certain aspects not
all aspects but certain aspects of the
Civil contingency system
is that current system too diffuse yes
yes the simple question I start from is
to whom does parliament to whom do the
public look to keep them safe to run it
the most simplest who is in charge of
making sure that this country is ready
to respond to all Nature's emergencies
but especially catastrophic emergencies
the inquiry is aware that in the field
of National Security there is a very
high level in government and National
Security advisor
but the evidence appears to suggest that
National Security has become over time
much more focused for very obvious and
perhaps senseful reasons on on
threats
terrorism is an obvious example as
opposed to hazards
has over time
in your opinion
has it over time the focus in government
on hazards and civil contingencies waned
by comparison to the focus on
malicious threats and and National
National Security
matters in the way that we we commonly
understand them to be yes that is my
belief indeed it's in Ms Hammond's
written statement as well that is not in
any way to diminish the work that is
being done on threats
but our position is that substantially
more work needs to be done on hazard
um if I may add uh conceptually speaking
we have a difference between civil
defense and civil protection civil
defense conceptually is a top-down
procedure or organization dealing with
threats which originally would have been
armed aggression by a state-based power
and more frequently now is armed
aggression by various dissident groups
civil protection instead which grew up
decades later is more about managing
hazards such as floods and so on it is
much more a bottom-up sort of Enterprise
because it has to be done and managed at
the local level or be it coordinated
harmonized regionally and nationally so
in some countries there is a very
distinct separation of the two in other
countries they are quite merged but
there is a distinct difference between
the kind of management of threats that
definitely requires a top-down approach
based on central government and the kind
of management of other sorts of civil
contingency that very much requires
local participation thank you
in your report gentleman you suggest the
creation of a role called the United
government Chief resilience officer you
referred Mr Manuel sofa
to the government's proposal of head of
resilience within Annex B to the
December 22 United Kingdom government
resilience framework wherein is the
difference
I I can't answer that question because I
don't know what is inside head
resilience the what is in the framework
is vague so I I'm afraid I can't answer
that but what your proposal
sorry Professor yes to do please answer
or if you can no no I simply concur
entirely with what Mr man says
but whatever post is created
must it be a post that is independent
that has serious political clout is
transparent and accountable accountable
to Parliament and has the ability to be
able to control the various parts of
government over which it sits yes and
that individual must feel that
accountability must feel that
accountability right
if the devolved Nations if I'm
civil contingency is a devolved matter
how would a UK Chief resilience officer
work
I believe that there would need to be
similar Chief resilience officers in
each Administration and then they can
collaborate together
within the context of the various
Devolution settlements so you're
suggesting
one for Northern Ireland one for
Scotland one for Wales
and a UK one or and an English and a UK
one
okay
there are some issues that need to be
addressed at a UK level in collaboration
with the default administrations there
are some issues which are England alone
there are also I think there are also
models of this in the European Union uh
where we have union-wide coordination of
Emergency Response planning preparedness
and so on and National and therefore is
a much bigger problem in terms of having
National resilience offices and National
advisors and so on
but it is so for believing at that level
how gentlemen would we avoid if if the
inquiry were to so recommend merely the
replication of another level of
bureaucracy another level of
governmental function
being superimposed on top of this
already very diffuse complex and
one may suggest over managed process
I believe in clear bureaucracy by
clearing that diffuse picture on
leadership
first point the second point is that I
believe this role belongs in the cabinet
office where there are presently two
entities who are dealing who are dealing
with a resilience and preparedness so
this may be no more than the designation
of a senior officer
who has that responsibility
clarifying responsibilities
accountabilities cleaning up the over
management you describe but drawing on
existing teams
and would
would you propose
an annual statement to Parliament for
such a position
yes I would uh
to actually each go back to your
question my lady to each Parliament
because this is a devolved matter
competence and training
where we're now related in the final
furlong
page 131.
in summary do you propose that in order
to make sure that
the people at every level in this system
are skilled effective
and uh and
recognized
that
I'm now trying to find whether it's
specific
um
recommendations are I think the
paragraph 379
that all local resilience forums and
government departments should have
suitably qualified experienced and
empowered personnel
there should be a single competent
strategy
and a framework to ensure proper
training and the checking of training
there needs to be a fundamental reboot
you say of the trainee ecosystem and
significantly
page
134 please paragraph 387 ministers and
their special advisors
must have a proper understanding or
basic understanding of resilient
structures and the basic principles of
Emergency Management
yes the root Point here is those who are
taking critical decisions in a
catastrophic emergency should have the
competence and training they need to
fulfill those those roles well
to necessarily superficial level for
today's purposes
what body of people took all the
important the primary decisions in the
course of the government's response the
country's response to the covid pandemic
[Applause]
was it in terms of of applying and
running this system in terms of making
the decisions in terms of
social restrictions how the various
governments would respond and so on
people at every level but starting in
central government which I think is a
point you're trying to make Mr Keith yes
then there would have been their
equivalence at local level and at Region
level and at evolved levels so it is
actually people at every level but
including especially the people making
the biggest and most critical decisions
and who took the biggest and most
critical decisions uh in the context of
covid-19 pandemic uh obviously Central
Central governments are in all four
administrations I'm pressing you Mr Man
because you know what I'm driving at
ministers thank you
Professor Alexander
yes the status and stunting of emergency
managers appears to have declined in
Britain at least that is what they say
when one talks to them there is little
or no career progression in this there
is also a tendency to cycle people in
government departments through
competencies that involve civil
protection and emergency preparedness
and then cycle them out of it again such
that expertise is lost
what we need here is to ensure that
there is
identifiable
career that there are identifiable
career paths and the means to pursue
them I think that's very important that
also I I believe there is now a growing
understanding of the value of involving
universities in providing basic training
it is recognized that in order to be a
good decision maker emergency manager
you need the background and the
understanding which you can get from for
example higher education
and you also need the experience to
combine with that about so 50 50 measure
which you can get from being on the job
but purely being on the job will not
give you an adequate understanding of
the Dynamics of emergencies
do you also refer at page 139
to
page
137 I apologize
to the need for a new Central resilience
Excellence that is to say a body to
promote the right principles to train
and to provide leadership to everybody
who
requires to be trained in this system of
civil contingencies
yes it goes a little wider than that
what does good look like it starts with
good
guidance it includes training it
including it includes a process on
learning lessons and it includes a
function which is to pick up good
practice in higher education
institutions other governments and so on
but its focus is on excellence
in the government's December 22
resilience framework at laxb we won't
bring it up but you referred to it
earlier Mr Mann the United Kingdom
government committed to taking the
following actions by 2025
to include
the delivery of a new UK resilience
Academy built out from the emergency
planning College the emergency planning
college is that a body that currently
exists I think operated by a third party
it currently exists as a joint venture
between the cabinet office and a private
company Circle
and
you understand or do you know anything
about the proposals to be delivered by
2025 to deliver a
Deliver us an academy I don't quite one
delivers an academy deliver an academy
built out from the emergency planning
college no I've not seen any of the
detail on that
um
has the government published
a single document stating the the rubric
or the the aims or the outcome or the
structure of such a body no I'm a
quite declare an interest I'm a senior
associate of the emergency planning
College I have not seen such a document
all right
um in Scotland there is a national
Center for resilience
is that an appropriate body
as you see it for the purposes of
ensuring excellence and and ensuring the
correct degree of training in Scotland
yeah Scotland has four bodies on
training on exercising Central
resilience and so on uh if you were to
hypothetically Stitch those together
that is pretty much what we had in mind
writing our proposals on the central
resilience excellent
thank you drawing all those threads
together
Mr Man
a man page 179 of the report
having examined all the structures of
which you've spoken today
having responded having identified the
correct doctrinal foundations
the integrated Emergency Management
all the the structures and the policies
currently in existence and ask yourself
the question
of the primary question were those
structures those policies those schemes
suitable or effective
in responding
to the covid pandemic
what was your conclusion
our conclusion there is a figure figure
six in this table which breaks down
what should be there and what should be
good which I suggest we don't go back to
in the interest of time
I did an assessment against every one of
those components
and that led to my conclusion which was
uh recorded a bit later in this document
the the vast majority of those
components were
poor
or non-existent
and therefore it led to my conclusion
that the uh
uh overall preparedness of the pandemic
was inadequate
was your conclusion that paragraph 523
and Professor I'll ask you to confirm it
in terms as well
that influenza pandemic preparedness in
England and for areas of planning that
were UK wide in their scope was poor
although the evidence suggests that
preparedness would have been stronger in
Scotland and especially Wells Northern
Ireland which did sustain activity to
build pandemic preparedness throughout
most of the period
the fact remains that three years after
exercise cygnus and almost 10 years
after aftein review
the Hein review being the review by Dame
Deidre Heinen to the 2009 swine flu
pandemic Kiera is a weakness the United
government's planning had not been fully
addressed Jews both stand by those those
propositions
yes
was preparedness for a novel infectious
disease pandemic adequate or inadequate
inadequate
had the response strategy put in place
by the United Kingdom government being
adequately tested in advance of covet
19.
in detail forensic detail to make sure
the plans worked on the ground no
was it clear in fact that Health and
Social care sectors were liable to be
overwhelmed that was the clear advice
not only from the hind review in 2010 it
appears in the signals report a report
of exercise Signet it appears in
officials advice to ministers it's a
Miss Helen's statement that they would
be overwhelmed which has to raise
serious questions about whether the plan
would not would have worked
and is therefore now radical
Innovation and change required
yes yes instructors and yes in the
detail in which
plans procedures whatever is issued from
whatever organization but especially the
central government are followed through
in detail to make sure that they will
work
and to that end gentlemen do you set out
at page 185
through
to 199.
47 separate recommendations which you
invite milady
to take account of yes
thank you
my lady
as with the previous Witnesses
core participants in particular
covid-19 brain famous and Justice have
indicated
that there are some questions that they
would wish to put you indicated
provisionally that you would be minded
to learn to put them in light of the
evidence has been given they are all
issues
which remain outstanding and so may we
have please your permission for them to
put the questions that they would
Mr Weatherby if you can make sure we
stick to the issues I give a commission
on
I sure certainly do that
thank you
um
the um first of all my name is Pete
Weatherby and I'm representing the
bereaved families and Mr Keith has been
through
most of the issues that I wanted to deal
with so I can be very brief in terms of
what Mr Keith has just asked you
um in fact in the report you refer to
the novel disease preparedness as being
woefully sorry holy and inadequate so
it's quite a strong finding isn't it and
it's in the report so I don't need to go
through it in any detail with you but
you identify the 2011 plan
as being
very deficient in terms of being a whole
system plan so the 2011 pandemic flu
plan is not a whole system plan is it
yes that's always good in the report
absolutely and
the points that you you make from that
is that despite the fact of the Hein
review
referring to a containment phase as
being an important part of a whole
system plan that didn't find its way
into the 2011 plan
that's correct and in the decade or
almost decade until the covid struck
no change was made to the plan to
include a containment
that's corrected yeah
and
um in in terms of the plan itself
you uh conclude that it's a Department
of Health Plan which ostensibly deals
with Health and Social care although you
point out it's very slim on the social
care aspect of that
correct
and
the further point is that by 2017 in the
light of the cygnus learning
efforts were then made to refresh that
plan but came to North because of the
brexit pausing exactly yeah
but in the course of of that the
National Security Council committee
was specifically warned about the state
of capacity within Health Care weren't
they Healthcare and social care yes I
stand corrected indeed so through this
period there was no whole system plan
and the plan such as it was was
deficient
known to be deficient
and by January 2020 hadn't changed
it was in my view deficient I believe it
was known to be deficient in 2017 I
wouldn't necessarily say throughout the
period yes
I have here that there was a
considerable amount of academic work
between 2003 and 2009 on developing this
scenario for a generic viral pandemic
and what makes this very particular is
that such an event is half a medical
epidemiological problem and have a
socioeconomic one the planning tended
not to concentrate on the socioeconomic
implications even though these were well
known
yes thank you Professor so what was
really needed with this was this whole
system plan that you talk about
or strategy that you talk about in your
report which would have covered all of
the issues that we've been through
Beyond Healthcare and and social care
yes you might call that a war book but
it has to cover all of the actions that
are taken in all of the sectors not just
I can understand Mr Weatherby your
focusing on Health and Social care
there's a range of other activity which
needs to be there as well yes indeed and
in order to then make that a whole
system strategy that has to be brought
together yes so whether we call the
Department of Health and Social care
um the lead government Department it's
certainly going to be one of the main
departments involved in any pandemic
strategy it has got a large part of the
comp management of the consequences that
there are other parts which which is the
point we explored with Mr Keith indeed
so
um in in terms of the responsibility for
the whole system The Point again you've
just been dealing with with Mr Keith
the point of having a single point of
responsibility is to ensure that the
relevant departments and Beyond
departments so their organizations as
well
their plans are integrated into this
whole system strategy and somebody is
responsible for making that happen those
two words those two points are exactly
my point yes integrated and
responsibility and accountability yes so
we we heard we learned yesterday that
the um civil contingency Secretariat
which of course you're very familiar
with
um has been split and there is a
resilience directorate
um now
um could that do the job of
uh being single points of responsibility
no I think you may have landed on the
wrong wrong part of the split there is
also the Cobra unit uh which could be
the single point of accountability I
would much prefer to see the shared
accountability between the so-called
lead government Department dhsc in this
case and the cabinet office to use its
power to bring everybody else together
right
is that it is too small I think it might
fit somewhere like the Netherlands which
in any case has highly devolved
emergency response but I think it is too
small for a country as large as complex
as the UK okay so the the body that
should be responsible for this whole
system strategy should that be within
the cabinet office or should it be
elsewhere
it's a European recommendation that it
be in the cabinet office and countries
have taken it up with a degree of
success so possibly yes the alternative
is to have a completely independent
agency and that certainly has some
advantages if it is tolerated adequately
as a solution by government yes is there
a problem with that Concept in terms of
ministerial responsibility because
sitting above this
um
sitting above the doers the the civil
servants who are going to make this work
has to be somebody with Democratic power
yes and Democratic responsibility
doesn't that yes and accountability yes
so does that work better
um with it with this being located in
the cabinet office or even a different
Ministry
I'm trying not to sound too geeky the
the issue with cabinet office ministers
is that they are rarely respond or have
not historically been
responsible for a particular piece of
operational activity so I think there
would be a prior question is this a
separate Minister oh let's say a
minister
in charge of a separate government body
the conversation we're having Mr Keith
yes or would we change the model of
cabinet office ministers over many
decades and have a minister with
explicit operational responsibilities
yes
I'll leave it there thank you
thank you very much indeed Mr weather
and thank you Professor Alexander Mr
Mann
um particularly you if I may say so
Professor Alexander given your
bereavement and your heart problems I
hope the heart problems resolve soon
that's very kind to you my lady and
thank you too Mr Speaker for being here
thank you Maeve that concludes today's
evidence 10 o'clock tomorrow please